So Leute auf gehts
Nachdem uns die Telekom gestern, oder vorgestern, oder vorvorgestern, ich weiß es gar nicht
mehr, ich glaube vorvorgestern, also am Dienstag war das glaube ich, uns mit einem Gaming-Router
beglückt hat, ist die Zukunft heute noch ein bisschen näher gerückt, denn wir probieren
heute das neue Windows in der Cloud aus, muss die Musik ein bisschen leiser machen, ja es
gibt jetzt von Microsoft Windows in der Cloud und man kann sich für eine Trial anmelden,
habe ich gesehen, und das machen wir jetzt, wir melden uns mal für eine Trial an und
probieren Windows in der Cloud aus, ich hoffe ich brauche kein Handy zur Account-Bestätigung,
sonst habe ich gelitten, aber das letzte Mal, also geht ja auch so immer mit Fake-Accounts,
ja und ansonsten, Chat was habe ich verpasst, ich war jetzt ein paar Tage nicht da, habe
ich irgendwie ein neues Twitch-Meta verpasst oder so, gibt es was neues, HotTube Streams
waren eh gestern, gibt es irgendein neues Twitch-TV-Meta M95, Alter erinnere mich nicht
an den Kerl, ich habe den vorhin noch geantwortet in den Kommentaren, der hat sich, oh Gott
es gibt Leute auf YouTube, das ist so geil, ok ok, ich zeige das Comment gleich mal und
sag was zu, einfach nur, dass man was zum lachen hat, was, wie, wirklich, das ist aber
schlecht, warum wisst ihr das schon und warum weiß ich das nicht, dass ich etwa not know,
do I lack critical information, kann das sein, lecke ich critical information, ist das so,
das wäre schlecht, egal sehen wir gleich, Stream wohl eher, ne da machen wir irgendwas
anderes, ja, richtig lost, der Boomer, wieder richtig lost, null, you lack cutie, das ist
wohl wahr, wobei, das kann der Chat ja ändern, ja das wäre natürlich doof, wenn das mit
trial nicht funktioniert, ja ansonsten gibt es irgendwas neues auf Twitch, was ich übersehen
habe, ich habe gelesen, dass es, ich habe auf Reddit gelesen, dass es einen Test geben
soll für Battlefield, einen internen Test für Battlefield 2042 und ich habe mir schon
gedacht, ah guckste mal in deine Mails, ob dich da irgendjemand angeschrieben hat, aber
nein, ich darf wohl nicht, kann ich auch verstehen, ich würde mich auch nicht zu einem Battlefield
Beta Test einladen, guck mal, ich mein, wen lädt man zu so einem internen Beta Test ein?
Leute, die das Spiel kritisch unter die Lupe nehmen und die auch mal sinnvolle Kritik üben
oder die ganzen Arschgriecher, die immer sagen, das Spiel ist perfekt, die das auch schon
seit Battlefield 1 und Battlefield 5 erzählen, wen lädt man ein? Jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen,
wen lädt man ein, logisch, aber nein, mal ernsthaft, mal ernsthaft, ich würde mich auch nicht
einladen, allein schon weil ich die, ich habe ja an den letzten zwei Spielen kein gutes
Haar gelassen, also ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die das dann nicht so geil finden, aber
auf der anderen Seite, gerade überlegt mal, gerade wenn man dann auch quasi Leute, die
die letzten zwei Teile sehr skeptisch gesehen hat, wenn man die überzeugt, dann würde das
ja nochmal besonders für das Game sprechen, aber ich wette mit euch eh, also die üblichen
Verdächtigen sind dabei, ja keine Frage, aber wie gesagt, juckt mich jetzt auch nicht
so wirklich, weil was bringt mir irgendeinen NDA Test, den ich nicht zeigen kann, dann
konzentrier ich mich lieber auf was anderes, Microsoft bietet kein Test, jetzt sag ernsthaft
jetzt, wollte mich verappeln, ich scheine wirklich Critical Information zu lecken, Leute, gestern,
gestern, morgen, ich lecke anscheinend wirklich ernsthaft Critical Information, das ist aber
schlecht, ok, warte mal, warte mal, Windows 365, der Cloud PC, tatsächlich es gibt, Moment,
das war hier in den Plans drin, tatsächlich, hier, aufgrund der starken Nachfrage bieten
wir keine Testversion an, registrieren sie sich und wir, jetzt, ok, CU, lul, gebated,
nee, aber was soll ich jetzt, das wusste ich jetzt nicht, ähm, war man da jetzt?
Ähm, gut, man hätte jetzt sagen können, ich hätte ja vorher mal nachgucken können,
aber warum strengen die so was ein, wir machen uns einfach ein Fa- also, ich kann, also,
ich könnte was kaufen, ich könnte es kaufen, aber ich will das nicht im Stream kaufen,
ich habe kein Microsoft-Account und ich glaube, ich habe auch kein Microsoft-Account, na doch,
mein Xbox-Account habe ich, warte mal, ich habe mein Xbox, ich habe doch mein Xbox-Account,
der Xbox-Account hat glaube ich auch, er hat keine aktuelle Kreditkarte drin, den Xbox-Account
habe ich vor 8 Jahren zuletzt verwendet oder so, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz Gedanken drüber
machen, jetzt mal, hast du nicht einen Account für Windows 11 gehabt, ja doch, aber ich
muss es kaufen, ich nehme noch keinen Fake-Account und trage da meine Kreditkarte ein, ich brauche
aber doch, ich muss es doch bezahlen, Fake-Kreditkarte, nein, ich mache doch hier on Stream nichts
Illegales.
In Argentinien kostet es nur 20 Cent, wo wir gerade beim Thema Kosten sind Leute, habt
ihr schon gesehen, dass die Prime-Subs jetzt billiger sind, kostet ungefähr einen Euro
weniger Prime-Sub als vorher, ist ja auch so ein bisschen umstritten, mal Twitch, Prime,
nicht kostenlos, null W, was, what the fuck, wo, was zum, bin ich hier gelandet, was, ach
so, Amazon, was auch immer, Alter, wir, wir, Karl, danke für den Sub, also es kostet
euch ein Euro weniger zu subscriben, aber die Leute kriegen auch ein Euro weniger ab,
also nein, nicht wirklich, also man kriegt die Hälfte ab und das ist dann insgesamt
weniger, also von dem Euro, der Euro geht weg, dementsprechend kriegt man auch von den
Gesamten dann halt von dem Euro dann auch nichts, Amazon hätte jetzt ja sagen können,
danke für den Sub Leute, vielleicht kriege ich jetzt einfach mehr Sub am Ende, man hätte
ja auch einfach sagen können, hey, wir, ups, Gripchat, wir geben den Streamern den Anteil,
aber was auch immer, ich bin mal gespannt, vielleicht gibt es insgesamt auch mehr Subs,
der Scamtrain ist am Start, ja, sind Prime-Subs dadurch weniger wert, ja, jaja, natürlich,
ich vermute ja eh, dass das ein Amazon-Trick ist, dass sie den Streamern weniger bezahlen
müssen, ich habe irgendwie die Vermutung, dass das ein Trick ist, dass sie sagen, hey,
die meisten Leute suppen ja eh mit Prime rein, danke für den Sub hier, Julian, die meisten
Leute suppen ja eh per Prime rein und Prime-Sub ist ja im Prinzip nichts anderes, wie Amazon
überweist ihr 250 für den Sub, ja, also ihr bezahlt euer Prime im Jahr und Amazon überweist
ihr 250 davon und jetzt müssten sie bloß auch 2 Euro überweisen, ja, man muss aber
auch dazu sagen, Prime kostet ja auch schon weltweit unterschiedlich, also Prime in USA
kostet glaube ich 120 Euro oder so, ne, Leute, ich glaube, ich muss den Videotitel ändern,
ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll, wenn es keine kostenlosen Trials gibt, kann ich
das nicht machen, ich habe kein Account mit Payment drin und ich will jetzt keine Kreditkarten
gedürnt on Stream eingeben, dann leake ich garantiert wieder irgendwas, das will ich
jetzt nicht riskieren, das muss ich ein anderer mal machen und mir vorher einen Account anlegen,
der das machen kann, ich ändere mal den Titel, ich ändere mal den Titel auf, was machen
wir denn heute, gbaited, challenge love, gbaited, gbaited, overrated, outdated, oder wie auch
immer, ich habe irgendwie noch dummes Emoji dabei, so, das ist der neue Titel, gbaited,
overrated, outdated, das neue Update von Windows 11 angucken, echt gibt es ein neues Update,
wirklich, dann schreibe ich das im Titel, Windows 11 Update, gibt es das, ich war mal
die Windows, ich war mal, Dankeschön Primesup Daniel, ich mache mal die Windows 11 VM an
und lasse das mal updaten, dann gucken wir uns das neue Windows 11 Update an, ja, wieso
war es eine regnerische Wolke, weil ich nicht glaube, dass es was taugt, zumindest in der
jetzigen Art, welche davon ist denn die richtige, ich glaube, das da ist die richtige, da wo
wir diese Packet Tracer Geschichten gemacht haben, mein Desktop, ich weiß gar nicht,
was der Chat immer gegen meinen Desktop hat, was habt ihr gegen meinen Desktop, ich kann
das überhaupt nicht verstehen, sagt mir eine Sache, die ich suchen soll, die ich nicht
nach 5 Sekunden gefunden habe, auf Chat, was soll ich suchen, was, was, was finde ich nicht,
Big PNG, haben wir nicht drauf, ISO 2 USB hier, M590 FPS, Internet TXT, da, ok, 4 Punkt
PNG weiß ich wirklich nicht, wo es ist, gibt es das überhaupt, ne gibt es gar nicht, doch,
ok, das wusste ich wirklich nicht, wo es ist, CA hier, irgendwo hier, gibt es nicht, es
gibt nur Kamera PNG, hier 4.2 PNG, das war kein Problem, bester Desktop, Kacknoobs, alle
keine Ahnung hier, der Chat weiß einfach nicht, wie man das richtig macht, der Chat
leckt critical Information, wusste es schon immer, soll ich mal das Ding hier zumachen,
yes, so, was habe ich denn hier auf, also was Windows Update soll ich machen, habe ich
gesagt, dann mache ich mal Windows Update, oh, das ging aber sehr schnell, CACWLW, alles
klar, Update, ich will Windows Update, Update, Update please, Check for Updates, ok, hat
jemand eine Übersicht, hier, Windows neues Bild, Bring Kompakt, dann schreibe ich das
jetzt mal in Titel, Windows 11 neues Bild, Windows 11 neues Bild, Eis, dann machen wir
das als Titel, es dauert jetzt eh kurz bis es geupdatet ist, da können wir uns noch
kurz ein paar andere Dinge angucken, die ich mir angucken wollte, so, Announcing Windows
11 Insider Preview hier, was ist das da unten, ist das sonst aber nie, achso, ich habe den
Rahmen noch eingeblendet, warum habe ich das eigentlich so blöde gemacht mit dem Minimi,
sagt mal, eigentlich ist mein Aufwähler richtig dumm programmiert oder, sagt einfach mal
ja Chat, eigentlich ist mein Aufwähler mega bescheuert programmiert, warum minimiere ich
das überhaupt, warum schließe ich das nicht einfach, guck mal, ich minimiere das Fenster,
ich könnte es aber genauso gut schließen und einfach neu aufmachen, ihr seht, guck
das wird minimiert, deswegen ist das Bild auch kurz links unten, richtig, oi, so, we
are very excited, gut, das ist ja schon, Moment, das ist gar nicht so neu das Bild oder, aber
es muss noch neueres geben, ach guck mal, es gibt jetzt Windows Bild 1, da müssen wir
in den Blog gucken, es gibt jetzt Windows Bild 2, 2, 2, hier, Kashis Blog, ich hab keine
Ahnung wer Kashi ist, aber da schreibt öfters mal ganz gute Beiträge, ich hab wie gesagt
kein Schimmer, das ist Kashi anscheinend, Family Safety, hä, ok, jetzt seht ihr Leute,
jetzt kann ja nichts mehr schief gehen, die Apple Watch sorgt dafür, dass wenn man schwanger
ist, dass man auch merkt, wenn das Kind auf die Welt kommt, haben wir in der vorletzten
Apple Konferenz gesehen und Windows sorgt dafür, dass unsere Familie safe ist, da kann
eigentlich nichts mehr anbrennen, so, das gucken wir uns gleich an, wie läuft das Update,
ok das dauert ein bisschen, Beispiel für eine gute VM unter Windows, nimm VM bei Workstation,
VM bei Workstation ist das beste eigentlich was du nehmen kannst, äh, Max würdest du
auf Windows 11 upgraden, wenn man es zu, äh, wahrscheinlich ja, ich werd erst mal warten,
ich werd, also ich werd auf jeden Fall nicht instant am Release Tag upgraden, aber ich
werd schon so innerhalb vom ersten Jahr upgraden, dort steht alles über die, was Fight, Leute,
ich bin nicht der Einzige der Fight Club gelesen hat, aber es ist Flight Hub, ach hier, Def,
Beta, aha, kannst dir eine Mac OS vor allem machen, das funktioniert nicht gescheit, also
wir haben das schon gemacht, wir haben ja schon mal, für MW3, ähm, der Player ist free,
ich sag jetzt erst mal kurz, also, erst mal dazu, äh, der Player ist free, der Player
ist aber nicht so geil, der kann glaub ich keine Snapshots machen, also ich würd mir
tatsächlich Workstation kaufen, kauft ihr einen Key, der kostet 20 Euro, da kann man
eigentlich nix dagegen sagen, bei irgendeinem Key Shop, äh, oder nehm Virtual Box, aber
Virtual Box ist ein bisschen pains-champiger als VM bei Workstation, so, und, äh, Mac
OS VM geht, aber ist nicht schön, weil, also wir haben's ja mal im Stream ausprobiert,
das funktioniert, funktioniert aber nicht gescheit, weil, ähm, es keine Grafikkartentreiber
für Mac OS gibt, für VMWR, die sind legit, ich hab selbst gekauft einen Key bei, bei
einem Key Shop für VMWR Workstation, äh, ich mein, du musst jetzt nicht beim letzten,
äh, russischen Darknet Key Shop kaufen, sondern bei irgendeinem normalen, dann, ja hier Leute,
aber Leute, ich, ich weiß, ihr meint's gut, aber hier keine Keys oder sowas posten, ne,
da muss ich euch timeouten, Modcheck, wir haben auch Mods da, das geht nicht, ihr könnt
euch die Keys besorgen, wo ihr wollt, aber nicht bei mir im Chat, whybedeath24, ja, das
würde mich nicht wundern, wenn der Kerl auch Windows Keys hätte, und VMWR Keys, der hat
alles, der hat sogar ein Video von meinem Klo geklaut, ja, also, aber hierzu wollte ich
jetzt noch mal kurz in Ruhe was sagen, während Windows Upgraded, ähm, ja, ich werde Upgraden,
ich werde nicht direkt zu Release Upgraden, ich werde Upgraden, wenn, ähm, so der initiale
Bass so weg ist, also wenn man weiß, dass das ordentlich funktioniert, ich werde zu
innerhalb des ersten Jahres Upgraden, wie gesagt, ich, ich, ich timeoute die Leute, ich
hab keine Ahnung, ob das ein legit Key ist, ich hab auch kein Bock, das jetzt zu überprüfen,
wenn irgendwie was postet, was so aussieht wie ein CD-Key, wird getimeoutet, und das
nächste Mal gebannt, fertig, ich hab da nix dagegen, wenn ihr euch das irgendwo sucht
auf irgendwelchen Seiten, aber nicht bei mir, ihr könnt es überall suchen, bloß nicht
bei mir im Chat, so, ähm, genau, also ich Upgrade wahrscheinlich innerhalb vom ersten
halben bis, halben Jahr bis, bis Jahr, sag ich so was kurz davor, also macht keinen Scheiß
Leute, ich kann jetzt mir nicht jede Chat-Nachricht angucken, ob das nicht wirklich ein Windows
11 Key ist oder, oder nicht, ja, oder ein FVM-Wallkey, das funktioniert nicht, außerdem sind die
Mods am Start, Windows 11 kommt bald in den Dev-Channel, ja, nice, wie gesagt vor allem
der Workstation ist top, ich wollte irgendwie noch was anderes kurz, kurz beantworten, ich
hab's aber verdrängt, hast du dir schon das Microsoft-Linux angeschaut, nee, so wie ich
das verstanden hab, ist das aber auch keine, also Leute, vielleicht hat das hier mal eine
Verwaltung von euch, aber so wie ich das gesehen hab, ähm, jetzt habt ihr ein Timeout, das
can't wait, bam, vorbei, Mods sind wieder unterwegs, wild heute, ähm, aber, so wie
ich das gelesen hab, ist das Microsoft-Linux auch nur eine Containerdistribution, eine
Minimal-Containerdistribution oder, deswegen hab ich mir das gar nicht näher angeguckt,
so, ich glaub, das war's, was ich beantworten wollte, aber gehen wir mal runter, aber sind
die legit, ja, also wie gesagt, ich hab's auch da drüber, hab ich nicht gesehen, ja,
klingt äußerst legit, kannst du mit deiner Grafikkarte GPU passt du in Vmware machen,
nee, unter Windows nicht, unter Linux weiß ich's ehrlich gesagt nicht, also Virtualbox
kann's unter Linux, vielleicht kann's vor allem bei Workstation auch unter Linux, aber
KVM kann's unter Linux, unter Windows geht das prinzipiell nicht, sag ich jetzt einfach
mal, weil ich noch keinerlei Desktop-Virtualisierung gesehen habe, unter Windows, die das kann,
das einzige Produkt, was das auch nur ansatzweise kann, unter Windows, ist Hyper-V und Hyper-V
auf dem Desktop zu laufen bekommen ist Pain's Champ und du hast noch andere Probleme, also
ich würd sagen, das ist keine Chance, das unter Windows zu machen, es wär cool, wenn
es ginge, unter Windows, ja, dann könnte ich mir in meine Linux-VM eine billige Grafikkarte
durchschleifen mit Video-Decoder, dann hätt ich nicht mehr 100% CPU-Last, wenn ich ein
YouTube-Video in der VM aufmache, es ist Hyper-V Pain's Champ auf dem Desktop, weil das glaube
ich gar nicht funktioniert offiziell, also doch, obbei weiß ich gar nicht, weiß ich
gar nicht, es kann sogar sein, dass es offiziell gar nicht unterstützt wird für Windows 10,
du kannst zwar die Sandbox installieren und den Virtualisierungs-Workflow, aber ich hab
keine Ahnung, ob das angepasst ist, ob das gescheit funktioniert, zumindest hast du die
üblichen Hyper-V-Probleme, USB funktioniert nicht richtig, vielleicht geht das mittlerweile,
das letzte Mal, wo ich gerade das Problem mit USB, du hast keine gescheite Grafikbeschleunigung,
wenn du es nicht über extra Grafikkarte machst und keine Ahnung, ob überhaupt GPU-Pastru
auf dem Desktop unterstützt ist, man findet dazu auch wenig, also ich würd mal sagen,
es ist Pain's Champ, ich hab es noch nicht ausprobiert mit der letzten Version, aber
es deutet alles auf sehr großen Pain's Champ hin, Hyper-V unter Windows Desktop zu verwenden
mit GPU-Pastru, ja, gut, dass man das installieren kann und dass das dann auch ordentlich funktioniert
mit der 2 paar Schuhe, ich hab übrigens, warum was sagt der Support, ich hab mir mal einen
ganz ganz billigen Windows Key gekauft bei irgendeinem Amazon Seller für 1,50 oder so,
also wirklich unglaublich billig und die haben mir auch gleich den Key geschickt und
dann hab ich versucht Windows damit zu aktivieren und dann hat Windows gesagt, nein, das ist
kein legit Key und wenn, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das schon mal hattet, aber wenn ihr versucht
Windows zu registrieren und es geht nicht, ihr könnt dann so eine Chatbox aufmachen
und mit dem Microsoft Support chatten und da hat sich dann irgendwie der Microsoft Support
in da gemeldet, wenn man auf diese Chatbox klickt und ich hab dann natürlich ganz unschuldig
getan und hab gesagt, ich hab hier einen Microsoft Key gekauft offiziell bei Amazon, ich kann
mir das überhaupt nicht erklären, warum geht denn der Key nicht, ich brauch doch ein funktionierendes
Windows, aber er hat keine Gnade gezeigt, der hat nur gesagt, Key ist nicht legit und ich
soll es zurückgeben, der hat sich, der hat sich, ja 13 Euro Key geht, aber 1,50 bei Amazon,
komm ich wollte es einfach mal ausprobieren, Windows Update 69% Poggers, das kann ich mir
vorstellen, dass das ganz gut funktioniert, da musst du aber Glück haben, dass du, also
spätestens aber so, spätestens mit Mac OS und wie heißt das Ding, Apple Silicon ist
eh vorbei, wenn die x86 dann mal unterstützen, du brauchst aber in dem Fall, wenn du in x86
Mac nachbaust, brauchst du halt irgendwie die, die ordentlichen Grafikkarte, die unterstützt
wird.
Was meinst du zu dem Scan, der in iOS integriert werden soll, kenn ich nicht, sagt mir nichts,
ich weiß nur, dass die unter Mac OS eine ganz coole Funktion haben, dass man seine Unterschrift
einscannen kann und dann automatisch unter Dokumente packen, geht unter Windows bestimmt
mit Zusatzsachen auch, aber das sind so sinnvolle Funktionen, wo man, wo man Apple wirklich
auch mal zu gut halten muss, die machen viel Zeug, wo ich auch sage, hey das ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht so das, wie ich mir die Programme vorstelle, aber Apple hat doch ab und zu mal
die eine oder andere sinnvolle Funktion, das kann ich jetzt hier von, sagen wir so, alles
was ich bisher von Windows 11 gesehen habe jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen, aber das war
unter Windows 10 auch schon nicht so.
Kennst du einen guten Shop?
Meldlich zu sein, nee, den, den ich gekauft habe, den will ich jetzt nicht unbedingt empfehlen,
keine Ahnung, wie geil der ist, ich habe mal früher Werbung für G2A gemacht, aber da
würde ich jetzt auch nichts mal kaufen, gibt es die überhaupt noch?
Wahrscheinlich gibt es die noch und die anderen kein Schimmer.
Wie das gehen soll mit dem Scan, ich habe es noch nicht gemacht, ich habe einen Kollegen
auf der Arbeit, der schwärmt mir da immer eins vor, ich gehe mal davon aus, du scanst
das ein, das stellt dann deine Unterschrift frei und du kannst dann halt auswählen bei
irgendeinem Dokument hier Unterschrift einfügen, so ungefähr stelle ich mir das vor, ich habe
das selbst noch nicht gesehen, aber wie gesagt, ich habe einen, der schwärmt mir immer davon
vor, wie geil das ist, dass er seine Unterschrift da elektronisch darunter setzen kann.
Geht ja unter Windows, garantiert auch, ist ja kein Hexenwerk, so eine Unterschrift freizustellen.
Ich habe gehört, die junge Union hat jetzt einen Twitch-Channel und streamt, da ist Philipp
Amthor am Game-Stream, Fall Guys-Stream habe ich gesehen und die haben keine Ahnung, was
sie da eigentlich machen, außer, dass sie ein wenig zum Fremdschämen sind.
Ich habe heute einen Artikel gesehen beim Vorbeiskrollen, wie man das ausschaltet, ich glaube entweder
bei Golem oder Heise, TPM, was bei Golem, irgendwo habe ich heute einen Artikel gesehen,
wie man das angeblich ausschaltet, so schalten wir den TPM-Zwang in Windows, mal gucken,
ob das nur G-Bait, ob das nur G-Bait-Artikel ist oder ob das wirklich, wirklich was hat.
Wir zeigen eine Möglichkeit, wie das doch klappt.
Ich habe eine Idee, soll ich mal raten, die booten das über Crap anstatt über Windows
direkt.
Also bla bla bla bla, Golem hat sich da, bla bla bla bla bla, okay, ach Moment, ist das
mit TPM nur, nur während der Installation oder was, Moment ist das nur die Installation,
ich dachte, das bootet dann später auch nicht mehr, da kann ich doch einfach eine SSD nehmen,
die schon installiert ist oder, okay Registry Einträge bei Setup, okay, es gibt wieder
die üblichen Registry Hacks, um das abzuschalten, alles klar, Bypass TPM Check, Bypass Secure
Boot Check, okay, tja, 2021 und eine IT News Seite macht noch Screenshots mit dem Handy
vom Bildschirm, gut, ich gebe zu, das ist schneller und einfacher, aber so ein Capture Ding anschließen
wäre doch auch in Ordnung gewesen, ja anscheinend kann man das, anscheinend kann man das ausschalten,
wäre ja auch, wäre ja auch gelacht, wenn das nicht gehe, bei Microsoft kannst du ja die
meisten Sachen mit irgendwelchen wüsten Registry Hacks ausschalten, der beste Registry
Hack, den ich in letzter Zeit gesehen habe, ist immer noch die, ach guck mal, die Taskleiste
umschalten von oben nach unten, das ist echt kryptisch, so, lassen wir das mal updaten,
ist Vmware von der Performance besser als VirtualBox, also in der grundsätzlichen Technik
ist das ja mehr oder weniger das gleiche, was die machen, ich würde aber sagen, ja,
die Performance ist besser, du hast bei Vmware die ganzen, die ganzen Treibergeschichten
dabei, die meiner Einschätzung nach besser sind als die Sachen bei VirtualBox, wie heißt
der Ordner nochmal für das Umschalten der Taskleiste, irgendwie REX3 oder so, ne, StepREX3
oder irgendwie so hieß das doch, ganz merkwürdiger Name hat das in der Registry, dieser Ordner,
ja, ich würde sagen, das hat bessere Performance, wenn du jetzt rein CPU Performance meinst,
würde ich sagen, nimmt sich das nicht so viel, CPU Overhead ist eben bei Virtualisierung
kaum noch vorhanden, also wenn du mal, also wenn man mal testet, ja, was ist ein guter
CPU Benchmark für Vm, äh für Windows, da kann ich nämlich mal in der VM ausführen
und hier ist seine Bench oder so, wobei ne, ja, ist wurscht, auf Ehrenbruderbasis Leute,
glaubt's mir einfach, wenn du CPU Last machst in der VM und machst du CPU Last auf dem Host,
das sind vielleicht 1%, 1, 2 maximal Prozent Unterschied, also du merkst kaum noch was,
also CPU Performance ist eigentlich nicht nennenswert unterschiedlich, ja, ich hab
Vm Workstation Pro, was Mac, ach ne, du meinst Hyper-V, ok, das muss nicht sein jetzt, also
bei VMs ist das so, das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was das für ne Technologie ist,
oh, er hat neu gestartet, hab ich jetzt, Moment Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich jetzt
das richtige Windows, Windows hab, bevor ich die anderen Sachen beantworte, Win, mach
hinne, hallo, ich hab 22000120, das ist, das ist die aktuelle, oder, das ist das, was
wir eben geguckt haben, was das ganz aktuelle ist von heute, zumal das License to Qt Weep
93 ist, das ist schon mal richtig, stimmt ja nix davon, also nochmal ganz kurz dazu,
es kommt n bisschen auf die Technik an, und was du machst, also Prinzip, also und was,
und was Hardware beschleunigt ist, also die CPU in einer VM, die würde ich mal als Hardware
beschleunigt bezeichnen, weil am wenigsten virtualisiert in einer VM ist eigentlich die
CPU, sonst wäre das nämlich auch performanstechnisch komplett, ja unbrauchbar, also ne komplett
emulierte, virtualisierte CPU wäre viel zu langsam, ich weiß nicht, vielleicht hat's
jemand, könnt ihr mal, schreibt's mal in den Chat, falls es jemand ausprobiert hat,
habt ihr mal ausprobiert, nen Raspberry Pi zu emulieren mit QEMU, ne armen CPU mit QEMU,
das ist auch auf nem aktuellen ordentlichen Desktop Rechner absoluter Pain's Champ, das
ist lahm as fuck, also das ist wirklich fürn Arsch, so und dementsprechend ist das am
wenigsten virtualisierte in einer VM eigentlich die CPU, also CPU Performance ist kein Problem
und ja, also die CPU ist quasi das nächste am Metall, was du hast an Hardware in einer
VM, alles andere ist je nach Technologie abstrahiert, also sprich die Grafikkarte, die du in einer
VM siehst, ist erstmal nicht deine Grafikkarte aus dem Host, sondern irgendeine billige uralt
Grafikkarte, die man in Software nachgebaut hat, und dann kommt's halt darauf an, wie
gut das ganze nachgebaut ist, VMWare ist da ganz gut, die haben beispielsweise in ihren
Gests, also in ihren VMWare Tools, haben die den Grafikkartentreiber für Windows drinne,
der kann in der VM DirectX machen, nicht 12, aber ich glaub mittlerweile sogar 10, vielleicht
sogar 11, ich weiß es nicht, und ein halbwegs aktuelles OpenGPL, was ist denn OpenGPL, Alter,
OpenGL, was ist OpenGPL, ist das neue Linux Lizenz oder 11, ok, also kann sogar DirectX
11 machen, Vulkan keine Ahnung, aber das ist immer noch nicht deine Grafikkarte im Host,
immer relativ clever programmiert, mit kurzen Wegen zwischen deiner echten Host Grafikkarte
und deiner VM, das ist wegen auch meiner Ansicht nach VM Workstation auf dem Desktop besser
als VirtualBox, weil die Grafikkartentreiber besser sind, so und alles andere ist komplett
virtualisiert, also wenn du USB anstöpselst an eine VM, dann geht das durch ein komplett,
oder Netzwerk, oder Netzwerk, dann geht das durch eine komplett eigene Implementierung
dieser Hardware nur für die VM, das ist quasi eine in Software nachgebaute Netzwerkkarte,
ein nachgebautes USB, wie das dann irgendwie durchschleifend zum Host, aber ansonsten ist
ja auch klar, wenn deine VM direkten Zugriff auf die Hardware hätte, dann kannst du dir
auch eine VM schenken, weil was willst du virtualisieren, wenn du im Prinzip in der
VM alles originale Hardware zugreifbar hättest, dann könnte man sich das virtualisieren spannen.
Und ansonsten, ja wie gesagt, das hängt ein bisschen von der Technik ab, unter Linux
gibt das, wenn du Linux in Linux virtualisierst, sagen wir mal mit KVM, Netzwerkeadapter kann
man durchschleifen, da habe ich aber so meine Zweifel, dass das geht, wo soll denn das funktionieren,
du kannst sagen Bridge Network, das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass das deine echte
Grafikkarte von Windows ist, die durchgereicht wird, das ist irgendeine Intel E1000, die
deine VM sieht, was dann unter der Haube irgendwie durchgeschleust wird auf deine echte Netzwerkkarte,
klar das kopiert sich die Mac von deiner echten Netzwerkkarte, aber hardwaremäßig Zugriff
auf die Netzwerkkarte hat deine VM nicht, klar die machen unter der Haube ein paar Abkürzungen,
dass das schneller ist, was sicherlich auch schon in der Vergangenheit zu ein paar Sicherheitsproblemen
geführt hat, es gab ja immer mal wieder die ein oder anderen Angriffsszenarien, wie breche
ich aus aus einer VM, aber der Sinn von der VM ist ja, dass die Hardware virtualisiert
ist, ja gut mit ESX kannst du das machen, gut also wenn du Linux, könnte Enterprise
Karten geben, die das können, ja ja Moment, Moment, da kommen wir ja dazu, wir sind ja
noch auf dem Desktop, also wenn du Linux unter Linux virtualisierst mit KVM, dann hast du
noch einen Zwischenschritt, die haben ein paar Treiber, die quasi im Host Kernel drin
sind und im Guest Kernel drin sind, die Abkürzungen nehmen können, zum Beispiel, dass du gescherten
Grafikspeicher hast zwischen Host und VM und sowas und das Disk IOU quasi auch nicht komplett
virtualisiert ist, also das ist dann, das nennt sich glaube ich para virtualisiert, aber nagelt
mich nicht drauf fest, also Linux in Linux virtualisieren kannst du performanstechnisch
ordentlich was rausholen, das geht mit Windows in VM-Version so nicht, aber Desktop-Virtualisierung
mit Grafikbeschleunigung sind die trotzdem besser, wenn du Linux in Linux virtualisiert
geht es ja hauptsächlich um Serveranwendungen, Netzwerk und Disk IOU und sowas, da ist das
richtig gut, so und der nächste Schritt, so die Hardcore Variante, wenn du vollste Performance
in der VM brauchst, dann gibt es die Möglichkeit, du nimmst entweder einen kompletten Hypervisor
als Host sowas wie VMWare ESX, das ist quasi ein Minimalsystem, was dafür gedacht ist,
dass du nur VMs drauf laufen lässt, die können dann allerdings auch, weil sie komplette Kontrolle
über die Hardware haben, so Dinge machen wie, wie reichen die Netzwerkkarte oder die Grafikkarte
oder den USB-Controller sogar direkt durch in die VM, das geht unter Linux auch mit KVM,
das funktioniert sogar mittlerweile relativ gut, bei ESX hast du allerdings den Vorteil,
dass wenn du im Business-Umfeld zertifizierte Hardware verwendest und zumindest eine supportete
Version verwendest, dann brauchst du kein Gefrickel und es funktioniert einfach, das
kann schon mal unter Linux ein bisschen gebastelt sein, aber es funktioniert mittlerweile auch
ganz gut, dann kannst du direkte Geräte durchreichen, so und da kommt jetzt das zum Tragen, was
Atonoxim geschrieben hat, es gibt da noch die Möglichkeit, das ist jetzt aber auch
eine Server Hypervisor Geschichte, also das ist jetzt eher was für ESX, KVM, eventuell
Hyper-V auf Windows Server, ich weiß es nicht, es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit, dass du
Netzwerkkarten hast, die selbst Virtualisierung können, also dann kannst du einer VM eine
virtualisierte Netzwerkkarte durchreichen, die aber Hardware virtualisiert ist, da brauchst
du dann irgendeine Intel Server Netzwerkkarte, das nennt sich dann, oh fuck, SR, Moment,
KVM, SR, S-R-I-O-V nennt sich das dann, Glocks HD, danke schön für den 21 mal, dann wird
es aber richtig abgedreht, da kannst du dann zum Beispiel eine physische Intel 10G Netzwerkkarte
Hardware virtualisieren in bis zu 8 oder 16 virtuelle Netzwerkkarten, die aber auch wirklich
als Interfaces auftauchen auf deinem System, die du dann wiederum mit Pass-Through in deine
VM packen kannst unter Linux, das sind dann aber auch so Dinger, das brauchst du echt
nur, wenn du Amazon im Rechenzentrum bist oder sowas, das glaube ich so für die normalen
Anwendungen doch recht uninteressant, geht aber, worauf man achten muss bei der ganzen,
ich weiß ein bisschen Side-Track, aber manchmal muss man die Sachen ein bisschen ausführlich
erzählen, worauf man achten muss bei dieser ganzen Hardcore-Virtualisierung mit Durchschleifen
ist, viele Desktop-Mainboards haben damit Probleme, weil durchreichen kannst du nicht,
also du kannst versuchen explizit ein Gerät durchzureichen, aber das geht nur, wenn die
PCI-Express-Bridge in ausreichender Anzahl sinnvoll auf dem Mainboard platziert sind,
du leitest nämlich in Wirklichkeit nicht etwa das Endgerät durch, sondern du machst das,
ich habe vergessen wie das heißt, ich weiß wirklich aus dem Kopf nicht mehr wie der Kram
heißt, du schaltest quasi das ab dem PCI-Express-Level um in die VM, genau IOMMU, das meine ich,
wenn das das ist, was unter AMD und Intel unterschiedlich heißt, dann meine ich das,
du schaltest das quasi ab dem PCI-Express-Level um, dein Host sieht die PCI-Express-Karte
auch nicht mehr, wenn du die durchgereicht hast in die VM, das heißt es ist oftmals
problematisch auf Desktop-Mainboards, wenn zum Beispiel drei PCI-Express-Slots an einem
Switch hängen, dann kannst du das gar nicht durchreichen gescheit, auch so ein Punkt
wo man sagen würde billige Mainboards, teure Mainboards unterscheiden sich da vielleicht
ein bisschen, mach da nicht meine Windows-VM ist jetzt am Start, ok exellent, gut, Jakob
ich hoffe das war jetzt ausführlich genug, du bist jetzt nicht total verwirrt, jetzt
erst mal komplette Abhandlung über VM gemacht, ok nice, wenn dir das was geholfen hat, dann
ist ja alles gut, wenn du was wissen willst sag Bescheid, Pepo G Leute, morgen wird abgefragt,
guck mal jetzt gibt es sogar ein Zap, ein Zap, ein Zapgegiftet gibt es jetzt, nice,
der Maya-RO hat dem Jakob ein Zap geschenkt, exellent, angelegte, 4€ exquisite, Dankeschön,
so, jetzt gehen wir nochmal ganz schnell den Chat von oben nach unten durch, ich glaube
sonst kommen wir heute nochmal dazu, ich bin ja wirklich die ganze Zeit nur am schwätzen
schauen, also bla bla bla bla, wie findest du eigentlich, ist das die, ist das das Ding
was mehr oder weniger auch in dem Stream Deck drinne ist, Steam Deck drinne ist, weiß nicht,
kam ich mir nur nicht angeguckt, Jakob so sind die Leute hier, die haben mittlerweile alles
so weit subscribt, dass der IQ in dem Chat so hoch ist, dass wir keinen Idioten mehr
haben, also wir haben hier nur noch nette Big Brain Leute, ist aber echt unglaublich
ne, jetzt mal ohne, jetzt mal ohne scheiß Leute, ihr wisst, dass ich auch gerne, ok
das Semmel outet sich wieder, aber gut, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regel wie immer, aber ihr
wisst ja, dass ich auch gerne mal in etwas größeren Channels gucke, wo es wild hergeht,
ich hab früher beispielsweise gerne XQC geguckt, als der Chat noch nicht eine einzige Emote
Wall war, was aber auch bei der Zuschauerzahl kaum zu vermeiden ist, und es gibt auf ganz
Twitch eigentlich kaum nen Chat, der erstens bei so ner Anzahl wie Zuschauer wie bei mir
so aktiv ist, ich mein, ich kann mich nicht beschweren so, wenn wir beim sinnlosen Labern
schon fast dran sind Leute zu gucken, aber das ist ja im Vergleich zu anderen Channels
gar nicht viel, klar es gibt viel mehr, die haben weniger, aber dass bei so ner Anzahl
erstens so viel los ist, und wenn ich mir angucke, wie viel dummes Zeug geschrieben
wird auf Twitch, dann ist hier wirklich exquisite 5 hat angesagt, das liegt aber auch glaub
ich daran, weil wir viele IT Leute haben, aber nicht nur, ich weiß wir haben alle möglichen
Leute hier am Start, ok gehen wir mal schnell weiter, weiter durch, das hatten wir schon,
hast du das bei deinen Praktikumsberichten so gemacht, keine Ahnung was sich das bezogen
hat, das hab ich irgendwie vor 10 Minuten mal erzählt, keine Ahnung, aha so ist das,
Leute ich war heute so getriggert auf der Arbeit, ich glaube ihr habt's auf Twitter
gesehen, wer auf Twitter am Start ist, wer nicht am Start ist, kann ja bald am Start sein,
der Carlson, danke schön für den Sub, Leute ich schau mal kurz nach, falls ich wieder
die Subs hier über sehen hab, Carlson, Juhu am Start wieder, ClocksHD, das Buttertoast
Pro ist auch am Start, Trevice, MattF, danke schön Leute für die ganzen Subs, ja aber
was mich heute richtig getriggert hat auf der Arbeit ist das, ich hab das ja ein bisschen
anonymisiert wieder, also folgendes, es ging da drum, es war nicht Nmap, es war aber was
ähnliches, wisst ihr was Nmap ist, also für alle die das wissen, Nmap ist ein Portscanner,
damit kannst du gucken was für Ports offen sind auf andere Rechner und Servern, was
auch immer, du kannst auch versuchen auszubekommen was für ein Betriebssystem, so wir hatten
nämlich heute mal wieder die übliche Diskussion, was ist ein, ah jetzt ja, ich hätte es auch
sonst erklärt, ein Port, gut muss ich nicht erklären, also, wir hatten mal wieder die
große Diskussion, dass es ja alles unsicher ist, was man zusätzlich auf seinen Laptops
installiert, so und jetzt passt mal auf, ich vermische jetzt ein paar Sachen, weil es um
das gleiche Problem geht, aber ich kein Bock hab euch drei Tage zu erzählen, also letztens
hatte ich das Problem, dass sie mir quasi verboten haben was zu benutzen, so und das
Problem was daraus resultiert war, ist folgendes, ich hab ja ein paar Programme auf der Arbeit
gebastelt, Tools und Synchronisationen und Import Sachen und so, also ich hab ja da einige
.NET Programme laufen und das hat auch alles wunderbar funktioniert und jetzt ging es darum,
ich würde gerne weiterentwickeln, kann aber nicht, weil man mir untersagt hat, dass gewisse
Sachen auf meinem Notebook zu machen, so MightyJTH, Dankeschön für den Sub und jetzt hab ich
letztens erzählt, ok Leute, also sagt ihr mir wirklich, also ich hab mit unserem Security
Mensch geredet, der war auch echt nett, hat aber gesagt, das geht nicht und er hat auch
leider keine Lösung und muss ich halt fragen, ok, heißt das jetzt wirklich, wenn ich eine
neue Version, wenn ich die Software, die ich programmiert habe, jetzt sag mal mal, maintainen
will, sagt ihr mir wirklich, ich muss folgendes tun, ich geh auf die Kiste mit einer IDE drauf,
entwickle das, kompiliere das, also in der IDE ohne das ich testen kann, ich kompiliere
das, ich schieb das von dort hoch nach OneDrive, geh dann auf meine autorisierte VM, lock mich
dort in OneDrive ein, lade mir das Kompilierte in OneDrive runter, kopiere das dann auf meinen
Zwischen-Hop, auf meinen Zwischen-Admin-Hop rüber, von dort auf das System, wo ich es
ausführen will, dort stelle ich dann fest, dass ich was falsch programmiert hab und dann
mach ich das Ganze wieder von vorne oder was, und er meinte, ja das ist so die, das ist
so eigentlich die Sache, wie es gedacht ist, ja, ne, mach ich, da kann ich nicht weiterentwickeln,
funktioniert nicht, gar nicht vergessen, so und heute, das war so die Vorgeschichte,
ich will da aber weder unseren Security, unseren Security-Mann flamen, der kann da gar nichts
für, wir haben mehrere Vorgaben, die widersprüchlich sind zueinander und das wird in Zukunft noch
sehr spaßig werden, zumindest heute hatten wir wieder was und da gab es die Diskussion,
ist es denn erlaubt Nmap zu installieren, wo, ok ich kann euch sagen um was es geht,
es ging nicht um Nmap, es ging um Wireshark, ich hab jetzt einmal Nmap geschrieben, weil
es einfacher zu erklären ist, es ging um, also in Wirklichkeit ging es um Wireshark,
also da haben wir gefragt, ok, nicht ich, jemand vom Support, die haben einen Dump geschickt
bekommen, da ging es darum, ok, wie machen wir den Dump jetzt auf und da meinte derjenige
vom Support, na gut, aber es muss ja auch eine Möglichkeit geben, wie wir das ohne
ein halboffizielles Notebook machen können, na gut, dann lasst doch mal fragen, also falls
jemand Wireshark nicht kennt, ich kann euch das mal kurz zeigen, was es da geht, Wireshark,
ich zeig euch einfach ein Bild, ich muss das nicht in, Wireshark ist ein Programm
um Netzwerkverkehr zu analysieren, sieht dann so aus, da siehst du von wann was geschickt
wurde, von wo nach wo und was es ist, ist wunderbar gerade zum Verfolgen von TCP Streams,
also Wireshark ist top, kann man nichts sagen, so und da haben wir gesagt, ok, es hat ja
keinen Sinn, dass das hier immer nur mit meinem halboffiziellen Lendungsnotebook funktioniert,
fragen wir mal und da hat der vom Supporter das machen sollte, dem sie Dump geschickt
haben, der hat dann gesagt, ok, ich brauche Wireshark auf meinem Notebook, man muss sagen,
das ist nicht Support in Form von Endkunden, 24 Team Endkunden Support, das ist Support,
die Eskalationen machen, also sprich Monitoring sagt Server kaputt, dann loggen die sich drauf
ein, gucken, ok, ist wirklich kaputt und suchen dann, na nicht mal IT Helpdesk, das ist sowas
wie Operations Center, sowas in der Richtung, ja und so und dann haben sie gesagt, ok, ich
brauche Wireshark auf meinem Notebook, so und dann ging es los, warum brauchst du den Wireshark,
ja weil ich den Dump habe, den ich mir angucken muss und dann ging das hin und her und dann
hieß es dann am Ende, nein, du darfst keinen Wireshark, also du bekommst keinen Wireshark
auf deinem Notebook, das war ja eh noch witzigerweise vorher, die Antragsorge war ja auch geil,
du musst, du musst, die haben versucht Wireshark zu beantragen, haben festgeschellt, in der
Standard Software Verwaltung ist Wireshark nicht drinnen, dann haben wir ein Ticket aufgemacht,
steht bitte Wireshark installieren, das Ticket wurde abgelehnt, weil heißt Freitextaufträge
dürfen nur Vorgesetzte ausfüllen, sein Vorgesetzter ist aber gerade im Urlaub, also sind wir zum
Vorgesetzten des Vorgesetzten gegangen, der hat es dann abgenickt und dann hat die Software
Verwaltung gemeint, nein, nein, also nach Rücksprache mit Security, geht das nicht,
da gab es keinen Wireshark, so und das ist das, wie meine Nachricht hier zustande gekommen
ist, überlegt euch mal, ihr habt Leute, die bezahlt ihr, damit sie sich um eure Systeme
kümmern, die haben Adminberechtigung auf so ziemlich allem was es gibt, von den kritischsten
Datenbanken bis zur Außendienstsysteme, wo das Frontend drüber läuft, die könnten,
wenn sie wollten, jederzeit alles runterfahren, löschen, zerstören, ins Darknet verkaufen,
aber sie machen es nicht, das heißt man vertraut diesen Leuten die wichtigsten Systeme an,
die das Unternehmen ausmachen, aber Wireshark auf Notebook installieren, das geht nicht,
das ist ausgeschlossen, das kann man nicht verantworten, das sind so Sachen, die verstehe
ich einfach nicht, das leuchtet mir nicht ein, also dafür, dass eingescannte beziehungsweise
elektronische Unterschriften nicht rechtsgültig sind, habe ich schon ganz schön viele NDAs
und Sachen unterschrieben, mit meiner nicht echten Unterschrift, die wahrscheinlich im
Zweifelsfall, wenn ich dagegen verstoßen hätte, ich hätte es nicht drauf ankommen
lassen, dass die nicht rechtsgültig sind.
Leute, ich habe die doofe Vermutung, wir kommen ja fast nicht mehr dazu Windows anzugucken,
ich labere, Leute ich bin jetzt fast eine Stunde on und ich habe nur vor mich hingeschwätzt,
okay ganz schnell noch Chat, wenn nicht, machen wir das einfach morgen, keine Ahnung, VLC,
du kannst VLC benutzen, VLC kann das, VLC, VLC kann das, FFplay kann das auch, Videos
um 90 Grad drehen, also VLC kann es ziemlich sicher, da bin ich mir aber nicht hundertprozentig
sicher, aber FFplay kann es hundertprozentig, Videos kippen, du kannst aber auch einfach
deinen Kopf zur Seite machen, ja VLC kann es umstellen, aber wie gesagt FFplay kann
es mit einem Kommando Zeilenparameter, oder du machst es über deine Grafikkartenoptionen,
das ganze Bildschirm drehen, also ich würde es wahrscheinlich mit FFplay oder VLC machen,
Buddha Toast Pro, da ich für den Zapp, Alter ich bin so weit hinten dran, Erics, ne, kann
ich das hier aufmachen im Stream oder ist das Toss, okay die Homepage sieht schon mal
paintschampig aus, ah coming soon, okay, tschüss, dann warte mal bis es Screenshots gibt, ich
bin einfach so weit hinten dran, meine Güte, Alter, ITJTH, danke für den Zapp, ja das
passt eben nicht zusammen, auf der einen Seite wollen sie agil sein, auf der anderen Seite
darf sie nichts machen, dann sagen sie auch wiederum so nach dem Motto es muss für alles
irgendwelche Workflows geben, aber auf der anderen Seite es soll alles dynamisch nach
gesundem Menschenverstand gehandhabt werden, das passt einfach nicht zusammen, vielleicht
kennt das jemand, vielleicht kennt das jemand, so nach dem Motto, okay wir brauchen hier
ITIL und da Workflow und sowieso und dann gibt es was, was ganz klar gegen den Workflow
spricht und dann kommt dann irgendjemand und sagt, ja Moment, aber der VIP Benutzer hat
doch schon angerufen, ja das machen wir jetzt nach gesundem Menschenverstand, scheiß auf
den Workflow, ich bin da sofort dabei, ich finde das gut auf den Workflow zu scheißen,
wenn der Workflow keinen Sinn ergibt, aber dann sollte man beim Planen der Workflows diesen
Fall zumindest mal in Erwägung ziehen, dass man sagt, okay es kann vorkommen, dass das
eben nicht eingehalten werden kann, aber das wird immer ignoriert, immer bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo es dann der Fall ist, so WireShark ist Poggers ja, oh ne, nein, nein, da werde ich
nie was zu sagen, das war ein Max aus einem anderen Leben, Stonks, Max, nein, nein, nein,
da werde ich nie was zu sagen, da mache ich nichts zu, ja das kann sein, wisst ihr was
das geile ist, wir haben Windows Virenscanner auf allen Linux Systemen mittlerweile, und
das geile ist, letztens hat mich ein Kollege angerufen in Teams, sagt hier Max guck mal,
das sind die Logs von Windows Defender, sagt ja, okay und weiter, dann meint er, guck mal
genau die Logs, da steht mein Passwort drin, also Windows Defender hat einfach mal sein
Passwort mit gelockt und nach Azure in die Cloud geschrieben, super, super geiles, super
geiles Security Tool, Security++ ist das, so ein Scheiß alter, so Leute ich muss jetzt
wenigstens mal das machen, was im Titel drin steht, wir wollten uns ja das neue, wir wollten
uns das neue Windows angucken, also die, die, aber eigentlich, eigentlich wollte ich ja
noch ganz andere Sachen machen, ich wollte mich ja über das eine YouTube Comment, zumindest
habe ich das im Sarix versprochen, dass ich über das YouTube Comment nochmal drüber
gucke und mich lustig mache, aber ja, was gibt's denn neues, wir hatten doch hier irgendwo
einen Blog Eintrag gefunden, hier Windows, also gucken wir uns das mal an, was ist neu,
was ist neu in diesem Bild, jetzt kommen die bahnbrechenden Neuigkeiten von Microsoft,
was gibt's hier, solltet ihr bereits Windows 11 testen, dann wird schon, neu ist hier unter
anderem ein Familien-Widget für Microsoft Accounts, ok, ich habe keinen Microsoft Account
verknüpft, ah doch, ich habe hier einen Fake Account verknüpft, braucht man ja, Family,
Apps, wie komme ich dahin, hast du dich schon mit, was, mit Petit, Petit, Potam beschäftigt,
ok, sagt mir gar nichts, ach, das ist der NTLM Angriff, ich sehe es gerade, ja, das
habe ich mitbekommen, ich habe keine Ahnung, was es da geht, null Plan, ich habe das nur
gehört, weil irgendwie eine Windows Administratorin, wir haben tatsächlich Mädels, die das machen
bei uns, irgendwas von NTLM Angriff erzählt hat vor ein paar Tagen und ich meine jetzt
explizit nicht Administratorinnen, sondern ich meine Administratorinnen, haben wir wirklich,
sind wir wahrscheinlich eine der wenigen Firmen, die das haben, was ich nice finde, so, also
wo finde ich das denn jetzt, Family Safety, Moment, da kann ich, ah, da kann man seine
Kinder überwachen, na das ist natürlich für die Leute wieder ganz toll, da kann ich überwachen,
wo meine Kinder sind und den Herz schlag oder was, ah ne, das ist wie viel der Monitor,
will ich das überhaupt, offizieller Blogpost, ok, will ich das überhaupt, also würde ich
das wollen, hätte ich Kinder, ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich nicht, wahrscheinlich würde
ich die gar nicht auf Steh und Tritt überwachen wollen, aber das ist noch nicht alles, Leute,
es gibt noch mehr, es gibt noch mehr bahnbrechende Windows Neuerungen, Changelog lesen, man beginne
unter anderem auch mit der Einführung des Benachrichtigungs-Badgets für das Chat-Symbol
in der Taskleiste, das da, get started, welcome to Teams, ah ne, ich darf mich auf gar keinen
Fall damit verbinden, wenn ich mich damit verbinde, das erste was passiert, die Leute
adden mich und schicken mir hier on stream irgendwelche Dickpicks, die dann in der Vorschau
aufgehen, dann werde ich gebannt, das mache ich hier ganz bestimmt nicht, also, hier guck
mal, hier ist das Benachrichtigungen, meinen die das hier, 4 new notifications, ne, warum
ist mein Kalender eigentlich immer noch auf Japanisch, ja gut, cuteweep93, passt ja zum
Account, ok, viel ist da anscheinend echt nicht drinne, da kann ich mich ja vielleicht
doch noch ein bisschen lustig machen, wobei wir haben uns das letzte Windows Update ja
auch nicht angeguckt, das müssen wir dann auch nochmal, wo ist denn das neue, hat jemand
zufällig den Blogpost zum, warum sind eigentlich, ich mein, warum ist das hier nicht als erstes,
warum sind moderne Webseiten so unstrukturiert, guck mal, das ist ein Post vom 5. August,
warum ist der Post vom 29. Juli oben, warum, und hier, was ist das für ein Scheiß, ach
hier, ok, da hätte ich im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, dass ich da gucken muss, ok, was
haben wir sonst noch neues, ok, das haben wir jetzt gesehen, Notification Badge, haben
wir auch gesehen, made some adjustments to improve how the close button looks in the taskbar
preview, Moment, in was, ah, wenn ich mehrere Explorer aufmache, oh, das ist ja hardcore
schnell mehrere Explorer aufmachen, sieht das jetzt anders aus, ist das anders, ich kann
euch leider nicht sagen, wie es aussieht unter Windows 10, weil ich hab das ausgeschaltet,
und ich hoffe man kann das unter Windows 11 auch ausschalten, hat jemand eine Ahnung,
ob es da schon ein Registry Hack für gibt, das muss weg, ganz ehrlich, das am liebsten
ist mir Windows, wenn ich von Windows nichts merke, und also aktuell geht das noch nicht,
wie kann man das nicht mehr ausschalten, geht nicht mehr, should we do a Registry, oh man,
ich will das nicht, dieses Feature hat mich unter Windows 10 schon hardcore genervt, ich
frage mich immer, für welche Leute das gedacht ist, gibt es wirklich Leute, die 20 unterschiedliche
Programme auf haben, ich meine ich überleg mal, was hab ich dann auf, also wenn ich ein
Video mache, dann hab ich auf Vegas, Browser, Browser hat eh schon mal Tabs auf, ein Explorer,
vielleicht Audio Aufnahme, das wars, Firefox und Chrome hab ich auf, ich hab da 6 Programme
auf, also ich hab nie, ich hab nie so viele Programme auf, dass ich die kopieren müsste
in irgendeine Art und Weise, 3 VMs im Hintergrund, ja siehste, die VMs hab ich, die VMs hab ich
mit dem zweiten Desktop, also ich persönlich verstehe das Feature nicht, ich sag jetzt
nicht, dass es keine Leute gibt, die das brauchen können, wahrscheinlich schon, auch wenn Microsoft
mal gerne Features macht, wo ich wirklich glaube, dass die keiner gebrauchen kann, aber
ich wills nicht und mich nervt es, mich nervt es jetzt schon, dazu kommt dazu, dass man es
auch nicht richtig zumachen kann, guck mal, hier, du kannst nicht alles zumachen, wenn
du alles zumachen willst, hast du jetzt auf einmal 2, Alter, ETF, so, rechtsklick alles
schließen, oh jetzt kommt Big Brain Time, gucken wir uns an, kann gar nicht mehr öffnen,
oh doch RIP, ich glaub ich hab es kaputt gemacht, oder nicht, wie lahm das ist, rechtsklicken
dann alles schließen, Moment vielleicht will ich ja gar nicht alles schließen, vielleicht
will ich ja, ok, mittlerer Maus, ok das heißt, wenn ich alles bis aufs letzte zumachen will,
muss ich dann folgendes machen, mein Gott, Explorer, geh halt auf, dann muss ich so machen,
ok das geht, nice, wenn man das weiß, ist in Ordnung, kann ich mitleben, ist in Ordnung,
der Explorer ist fucking langsam, das könnte aber auch ein bisschen an der VM liegen, aber
ich wüsste ehrlich gesagt nicht, warum, kann man jetzt Explorer mit Ctrl W jetzt schließen,
Henry, danke schon für den Sub, hat es jetzt eigentlich Tabs im Explorer, nee ne, das wäre
ja auch was, ok, also was haben wir sonst noch, Glow's Icon sieht jetzt anders aus, changing
Backgrounds, das juckt mich nicht, Moved Identify Button in Display Settings, das ist mir auch
egal, Updated File Explorer's Context Menu to be a little more compact for Maus-Users,
was heißt hier denn for Maus-Users, also ich bin jetzt klar, Maus-Users sind 90% der Leute,
sollte erstmal hauptsächlich für Maus, das ganze Ding sieht nicht aus wie vor Maus-Users
gemacht, doch Windows-Virtualisierung ist, also Windows unter Windows-Virtualisierung
ist noch ganz in Ordnung, ich mein Linux ohne irgendwelche Oberflächen die Acceleration
brauchen ist besser, aber das ganze Ding sieht nicht aus wie für Maus-User, wenn ich ehrlich
bin, das ist ein Trend der mir persönlich schon seit bestimmt den letzten 6-7 Jahren
auf den Sack geht, auf dem Desktop, dass immer mehr Desktop-Programme tabletifiziert und
touchifiziert werden, von der Bedienung, unsinnigerweise, weil kaum jemand verwendet
das auf dem Desktop mit Touch, auch so ein Ding was mich bei Firefox nervt, aber das
finde ich schon mal nicht schön, obwohl es im Prinzip mehr oder weniger der gleiche Mist
ist wie bei jetzt schon in Windows, aber ich mag das nicht, dass es sich ver-tablifiziert,
ihr findet ja Power-Toys, was Shift-F10, was macht Shift-F10, ach das ist noch das alte,
Moment warum gibt es da noch beide, oh nee oder ernsthaft, nein, please Microsoft, nicht
jetzt da auch noch zwei Dinge, muss das sein, jetzt wirklich, es gibt wirklich ein doppeltes
Kontextmenü, allen Ernstes ja, ach du Scheiße, jetzt weiß ich auch warum es die Frau von
Bill Gates hat scheinen lassen, die konnte sich das ehlern nicht mehr mit angucken, gut
Bill Gates hat damit ja überhaupt nichts zu tun mehr, so also, das gefällt mir nicht,
ich hab gehört die sind jetzt auch wirklich geschieden vor drei Tagen oder so, ist jetzt
durch, so also das haben wir uns anguckt, haben wir uns auch anguckt, update the new button
in file explorer's command bar, hochgradig, augers, ein new button, unglaublich, was die
hier alles machen bei Microsoft, das ist ja quasi komplett neu erdacht Windows schon,
unglaublich, also bei Microsoft die hauen echt ein nach dem anderen raus, gut wir sollten
jetzt, ich darf jetzt Microsoft nicht zu sehr flamen, ich meine, ich finde das wirklich
gut, ja ich hab mal irgendwann Open Office zum testen, ich finde das wirklich gut, dass
es diese Previews gibt, also das muss man Microsoft wirklich auch mal zu gut halten,
dass die diese Preview Builds überhaupt machen, ist deutlich deutlich besser als das was sie
früher gemacht haben, im stillen Kämmerlein rumgewurstet und dann kam eine neue Windows
Version raus, dann kommt da sowas wie Windows 8, ich glaube so schlimm wie Windows 8 wird
das jetzt nicht, Windows 8 war ja zu Release absolut weird champing, Vista war noch viel
besser als Windows 8, weil Vista war nur die Frage, warum sollte man es sich installieren,
bei Windows 8 war eher die Frage, was kann ich, wie kann ich mich dagegen wehren, ja,
Windows 11 ist doch eigentlich nur Windows 10 Redesign, naja, Microsoft sagt nein ist
es nicht, sie haben angeblich am Unterbau auch einiges gemacht, da hab ich ein bisschen
meine Zweifel, unter anderem gab es Benchmarks, dass Spiele paar Prozent schneller sind, was
ich mir auch durchaus erklären kann, gerade das erste Windows 11 Build hatte ja faktisch
keinerlei Hintergrundprogramme, du hattest standardmäßig in Windows 11 5 Programme oder
so, wo war jetzt nochmal der Task Manager, das ist jetzt neu, man kann den Task Manager
nicht mehr aufmachen, was war der Task Manager nochmal, außer Control Alt N, da gab es doch
jetzt was neues, Control Shift Escape, auf Windows Rechtsklick, Massive Brain Chat wieder
hier, dazu kann ich nur sagen, Koggers, hab ich einen Prozess Explorer noch drauf, also
da läuft wenig im Hintergrund, das ist für Windows Verhältnisse, ich brauch mal einen
Prozess Explorer, sonst erkenne ich dir nichts, zack, Open Console, zack, zack, zack, zack,
ja ja, Close, hier, Admin starten, yes, yes, ist gut, so, jetzt mal nach CPU sortieren,
es ist doch schon wenig, was da läuft im Vergleich zu Windows 10, oh nee, es gibt jetzt zwei
Windows Defender, einer hat nicht gereicht, einer hat nicht gereicht, wir brauchen jetzt
zwei, hat sich geforkt, guck mal, als hätte er es gemerkt, jetzt ist er weg, als, ah nee,
da ist er noch, enttarnt, Exposed, doppelter Defender, doppelter, ist Windows Defender
nicht gut, doch, doch, also seit Windows Defender gebundelt ist, ich würde mir heutzutage kein
extra Windows Antivirus installieren, aber ich hab mich jetzt nur ein bisschen drüber
lustig gemacht, weil es auf einmal zwei sind, das ist ja streng genommen wahrscheinlich
schon immer so, dass das mehrere Services hatte, aber jetzt gibt es anscheinend noch
einmal einen, der halt auch so heißt, das war jetzt nur so zur Hälfte ernst gemeint,
aber ich find's schon interessant, dass da ein zweiter jetzt da ist, so, es gibt ganz
viele Edge, warum auch immer, aber ich mein, das ist unter anderem ein Punkt, wo ich mir
denken könnte, ja allein schon deswegen ist das ein bisschen schneller, weil weniger Hintergrundprozesse
laufen, das hätte man bestimmt in der Windows 10 auch machen können, ja, ok, also was haben
sonst noch schönes neues, some adjustments to improve, was, the use of space and thumbnail
sizes within Alt-Tab, aha, also sprich hier, das ist jetzt Kleine und der Unter-Task-View,
is the moment, enter passports, weißt du jetzt da mehr, nein geh weg, gehst du weg, gehst
du weg, gehst du, gehst du weg, das will, das will nicht, das will sich nicht abschütteln
lassen, ganz ehrlich, das wird eh kompletter Reinfall, niemand hat nach neuen Windows Widgets
geschrien, das ist electron based, glaub ich nicht, ich glaub, das ist eher WinRT, WinUI
3, also quasi der UWP-Nachfolger vermute ich jetzt mal, so fixes, na gut fixes guckt
man uns jetzt nicht an, das ist jetzt für uns jetzt erstmal egal, so, was hat sich
sonst noch neues getan, das ist jetzt auch neu, das haben wir uns nämlich auch noch
nicht angeguckt, changes and improvements, we have done well, chat, das haben wir gesehen,
das will, dass ich ein paar Teams anmelde, mach ich aber nicht, hidden icon fly out on
the lower right of taskbar, spin update to match new visual style, das da oder wie, ok,
ist jetzt so viel anders, ist jetzt so viel anders, ja, ja, es ist nicht mehr durchsichtig,
uiuiui, da haben sie aber richtig zugelangt, warum, automatic sample submission, was sagt
mir das, ok, turn on, ja, mach, mach, alles gut Windows, setup onedrive, das ist so eine
Microsoft Sache, die finde ich nicht gut, warum sagt das security center, bitte benutzt das
Microsoft Filesync Produkt, das hat doch damit gar nichts zu tun und dismissen kann man den
shit oned, das heißt, wenn man keinen Bock auf onedrive hat, bedeutet das, ja, ich weiß,
dass es für backups gedacht ist, aber letztendlich ist es ja, hat es ja mit security center nichts
zu tun, wenn Microsoft ihre eigene Cloud Lösung da anpreisen will, außerdem security technisch
könnte ich sogar eher, würde ich sogar eher sagen, wenn man die Daten nicht unbedingt
einfach ohne, hinlos, ohne sich Gedanken zu machen in die Cloud lädt, ist das wahrscheinlich
sogar sicherer, was, setting to block, potential unwanted apps is turned off, ok, turn on,
so, ist das security center, ist jetzt alles gut im security center, ja, jetzt ist es zufrieden
mit mir, ok, also das ist jetzt das, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, hier sind die Ecken abgerundet,
hier sind die Ecken abgerundet, das stimmt nicht, ok, wir switchen themes, was, nichts
weiter, ah ja, mache ich doch jetzt, to use your mode light, so, bam, da ist es, da ist
es, Leute, abgerundete Ecken, da ist es, endlich, oh, was jetzt, was ist das, nein, kann ich
das beenden, Wahnsinn, absoluter Wahnsinn, der Wahnsinn schlechthin, so, also was haben
wir als neues, als noch neues, ability to quickly access focus assist settings, die haben
auch für alles irgendwelche Namen, die man sich nicht merken kann, ich meine, jetzt mal
ernsthaft, wenn ihr euch überlegt, wie hieß das nochmal, wo ich die notifications ausschalten
kann, das sagt doch keiner, ah klar, klar, natürlich, focus assist, natürlich, könnt
ihr es nicht einfach notifications settings nennen oder so, warum muss das focus assist
heißen, ah, Moment, Moment, Moment, focus assist war ganz was anderes, das ist, wir
machen den Bildschirm gelblich ab 23 Uhr, oder, äh, ach ne, der muted einfach nur notifications
zwischen 23 und 7 Uhr, das ist bei meinem Bedge, Bedgetime, wenn man im Bedge ist, dass man
keine notifications kriegt, warum, ist dann hier unten nicht einfach ein mute button,
das haben die doch sogar unter Windows 11 hingekriegt, guck mal, so unter Windows 11 hast du hier
unten einfach einen Knopf und kannst sagen, ähm, muted, notifications aus, und ich muss
euch ehrlich sagen, also so ein, so ein Button, um das zu muten, finde ich von der Idee her
gar nicht so doof, wie geht denn jetzt focus assist wieder auf, ach, ok, letztendlich hat
es überhaupt keinen Sinn sich daran zu gewöhnen, ich verwende die Funktion eh nicht, also ganz
ehrlich, ich hab dieses Menü noch nie aufgemacht, weil ich irgendwas hier drinnen machen wollte,
das einzige wozu ich dieses Menü manchmal benutzt habe, ist um Bluetooth ein und aus
zu schalten, das ist aber auch alles, was ist, was ist das für ein Screen, den man gerade
sieht, äh, äh, äh, was, das da, das ist, hier, das ist Windows 11 Kalender, und das
davor war Windows 11 Notification Menü, hast du das mitbekommen mit den Alterssachen im
Betriebssystem, ne, kann man aber eh wahrscheinlich easy as fuck austricksen, wobei es mir ein
bisschen auf den Keks geht, letztendlich, man muss doch nicht den Herstellern, man braucht
doch nicht für alles irgendwelche Einschränkungen, die eingebaut sind, man muss doch auch mal
ganz klar sagen wie es ist, letztendlich müssen die Eltern natürlich gucken, was ihre Kinder
vor dem Rechner machen, die tun immer gerade so mit solchen Settings, als könnte man das
denen irgendwie abnehmen, kannst du doch nicht, du kannst doch, du kannst doch da Leute nicht,
du kannst, du kannst doch die, die Kinder nicht, ähm, wenn sie noch gar keine Ahnung
voller Technik haben, alleine ins Internet lassen, da musst du dich doch eh drum kümmern,
also wenn du nicht willst, dass du irgendwelche, äh, für immer verstörten Kinder hast, ja,
du musst, du musst dich doch eh damit beschäftigen, wenn du da keinen Bock drauf hast, da bringt
es auch eine, eine Jugendschutzsicherung nicht, oder eine Kindersicherung nicht, und wenn
du das machst, dann brauchst du wahrscheinlich die Kindersicherung nicht mehr, ne, das habe
ich nicht gesehen, na, eh, gut, letztendlich lässt sich das eh immer easy austricksen,
so, aber es gibt sonst noch ein neues, Background Activity leuchtet die App dann unten rot,
ok, das ist tatsächlich ganz nützlich, wobei man sich jetzt natürlich fragt, warum gibt
es dann kein Notification der neuen Notification Bar, anstatt unten rot zu leuchten, aber ich
finde es ok, dass es unten rot leuchtet, es ist mir lieber als die Notification Bar zu
verwenden, Touch, Keyboard, Taskbar, Kalender, Flyout, was für ein Ding, Taskbar, Kalender,
Flyout will now fully collapse, down and clicking, der, der, diesen Pfeil nach unten, ok, also
das, wenn ich das hier anklick und auf den Pfeiler unten dann Collapses, aha, huge, endlich,
da warte ich schon drauf, schon lange, mindestens 20 Jahre, dass es das endlich gibt, so, in
der Microsoft Store, gut, das überspringen wir, wen juckt der Microsoft Store, New Animations
im Store, huuuh, Zwangsfilter für alle Webseiten, das lässt sich doch nicht umsetzen, ich, ich
habe ja, ich habe ja vor einer Weile in einem Video zugemacht, dass ich VPN-Anbieter bescheuert
finde, aber es gibt in letzter Zeit immer mehr Entscheidungen, wo ich mir denke, eventuell
braucht man den Grand Dommer irgendwann, wobei wenn es soweit ist, dann darf man das wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr benutzen, ohne sich strafbar zu machen, weil es gibt ja auch Leute, die sagen,
ich will Verschlüsselung verbieten, ok, ok, Big Farm, Mobile Harvest, genau, perfekt,
da will ich mir jetzt die geilen Animationen angucken, oh Wahnsinn, diese Animation, noch
nie gesehen, noch nie da gewesen auch, also, ne, unglaublichste Animation, oh wir müssen
den Store erstmal, ah Moment, Moment, das ist ja gar nicht das neue, wir müssen erstmal
den Store updaten, langsam, langsam, man hätte jetzt vermuten können, dass ich zumindest
den Store selber über Windows Update updaten, aber da habe ich falsch gelegen, Teddy, Dankeschön,
14 Monate, hat er den Teddy geslayt hier, hat er ganz schön lang gedauert, 14 Monate,
um den Teddy zu slayen, aber danke für den Sub, 14 Monate Prime Subscription, du kannst
dich freuen, dein Prime Sub kostet Amazon jetzt weniger Geld seit zwei Tagen, nämlich
nur noch 2 Euro statt 2,50 Euro, aber du bezahlst natürlich immer noch das Gleiche, das ist
ja klar, nicht, dass man jetzt irgendwie denkt, dass man kriegt das, ne, ne, ne, Jeff hat
einfach mehr Geld, so, Update, bekommst du jetzt weniger Geld für den Sub, ja, ok, dann
gucken wir, komm wir gucken das Video jetzt noch, ich glaube, weil unter Windows gibt's
jetzt nicht so viel mehr anzugucken, den Store, die neuen Massive Animationen muss ich mir
aber noch angucken, oh die Solitär Collection, jawoll, die Solitär Collection Leute, da
ist sie, die Solitär Collection, endlich, ok, Restart, endlich Candy Crush, ist das,
ist das immer noch ein Ding, spielen das immer noch, ja weil, aber ist blöd, man soll natürlich
spielen das immer noch Leute, sonst gibt's den Scheiß dann immer, früher gab's noch
Peggle und, und, Moment, lass mal überlegen, was war so das richtig erste Mobile Hype
Game, Angry Birds oder, ich mein Casual Gaming ist ja, ist ja schon, also der erste, der
erste, das erste richtig krasse Casual Game, wo's jeder gespielt hat, der da mit nichts
zu tun hat, war Mohun, 1998 oder so, so und Mobile, also Angry Birds war aber schon, war
aber schon, Doodle Jump, nee Doodle Jump kam doch spät, das war noch nach Angry Birds
oder, Snake 2, so, Store, guck mal jetzt haben wir ja auch neue Benachrichtigungen,
ok, Store, check out das Update, machen wir, so pass auf jetzt haben wir Massive Animation,
boah, man hat wirklich neue Animation, jetzt, jetzt erscheint der Shop gleich wie neu, komplett
in neuem, äh, animierten Klans, der, also jetzt, jetzt, vorher hätt ich gesagt war
der Shop nur so, naja, aber jetzt, mit den neuen Animationen ist der Shop natürlich
top, nee, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich erkenne eigentlich gar keinen Unterschied, es ist
ein bisschen schneller und es fade ein bisschen mehr, aber ich erkenne nicht wirklich den
Unterschied, it's, ja, Magic, so, wie war das jetzt, ich soll mir dieses Video noch angucken,
habt ihr gesagt, wo ist das Video, Wit, wo ist das Wit, das da, das da, ah, er wieder,
ja gut, wer auch sonst, also, guck mal, der hat Upgraded mit Green Screen im Hintergrund,
was ist denn da los, das ist ja richtig, richtig, wie Logger hier mittlerweile, voll advanced,
richtig professionell, Moment, Moment Leute, ich muss jetzt mal ganz kurz bei mir unter
das Video gucken, ob, ob mein Lieblingskommentator der letzten, äh, zwei Tage geantwortet hat,
passt mal auf, haltet euch fest, ihr werdet jetzt richtig massive, äh, Gehirnzellen verlieren,
wenn ihr das lest, aber, deswegen, ähm, haltet euch am besten die Ohren zu, dass nichts raus
läuft, dass ihr keine Gehirnmasse verliert, aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal was, ach guck
mal, der Eax war auch am Start sich jetzt erst, so, also wer das Video nicht kennt,
gibt's jemanden, der das Video nicht gesehen hat, wahrscheinlich, ich sag nur mal ganz
kurz was zu, also TLDR, Telekom hat eine Gaming-Router rausgebracht und ich verstehe den Sinn der
meisten Features davon nicht, ich sage im Video, dass ich sinnvoller finde, anstatt
400 Euro für den Telekom-Router auszugeben, man, äh, sich auch, äh, was anderes kaufen
kann und dafür die Wohnung lieber mit, ähm, ein paar einzelnen Access Points ausstatten
soll, dass man eben auch auf der Terrasse Empfang hat und wenn es unbedingt Gaming sein muss
über WLAN, dann, halt, geht das auch ohne Gaming-WLAN, zumal, übrigens, wisst ihr was
ich witzig finde, passt mal auf, passt mal auf, passt mal auf, jetzt muss ich euch mal
kurz zeigen, äh, äh, Speedport Pro Plus Pure-Wi, die haben einen, der verdammt ähnlich aussieht,
zu dem Speedport, ich würde, ich würde fast wetten, der Speedport basiert auf, auf diesem
, guckt mal, das ist der, der, der, der, wie sprühe ich aus, URY-Router und das ist der
Speedport, ja, außer, dass das Gehäuse schwarz ist, also, er ist, er ist schon, sag mal mal,
zumindest, zumindest inspiriert und ich vermute fast, dass, dass die gleiche Hardware oder
ähnliche Hardware, die Specks sind nämlich auch sehr ähnlich, die Specks sind nämlich
auch sehr ähnlich, nur, dass der Telekom-Router kein 5G kann, hast du schon mal mit Kafka
gearbeitet, wie lernt man das, indem man das installiert und ausprobiert, ich weiß
nur, dass es eine Message-Q ist, die zurzeit voll angesagt ist, ich hab damit noch nicht
viel gemacht, ja, also, wahrscheinlich haben die im Endeffekt nur das Web-Interface gebaut,
wahrscheinlich ist die Custom-Firmware sogar von URY, aber egal, so, das hab ich im Video
schon früher gesagt, so, und da war einer, also, die meisten haben mir ja zugestimmt
oder hatten ein paar Punkte, wo die gesagt haben, okay, Maxi ist ein bisschen anders,
aber einer hat echt wieder den Vogel abgeschossen, und zwar, wo ist er denn, wo ist er denn,
hat das Comet gelöscht, da ist er, da ist er, da ist er, also, also, ich muss mal kurz
gucken, ob er geantwortet hat, nein, hat er nicht, oh, schade, jetzt hab ich gerne mal
die Antwort durchgekriegt, also, ähm, der muss das voll wissen, erst mal, Wall of Text,
muss da, jetzt muss das mir geben, und Leute, wir gucken uns jetzt dieses Comet an, denkt
dran, er erwartet da jetzt eine seriöse, professionelle Antwort auf dieses Comet, das muss man immer
im Hinterkopf behalten, wenn man das liest, also, er hat quasi das Comet so geschrieben,
dass ich darauf eine seriöse, professionelle Antwort schreibe, so, okay, also, pass mal
auf, also, der MrSnotty ist am Start, dachte, hier geht's um eine professionelle Einschätzung
zum Router, leider doch nur ahnungsloses Geschwurbel, also, es ist immer eine sehr gute, eine sehr
gute Idee, ein Kommentar, auf den man eine seriöse, professionelle Antwort erwartet,
so anzufangen, also, merkt euch das, es ist immer gut, wenn ihr eine sinnvolle Antwort
haben wolltet, anzufangen mit, alter, du kacksparst, so nach dem Motto, das kommt immer gut, kommt
immer gut an, da werdet ihr sehr viele seriöse und professionelle Antworten drauf bekommen,
okay, ich frage mich immer, warum solche Videos so viele Likes bekommen, naja, wahrscheinlich
weil mir die Leute zustimmen zum größten Teil, äh, wegen dem Gaming Video im Hintergrund
der sympathischen Sprache, das Inhaltswegen jedenfalls nicht, destroyed, komplett, teilweise
völlig wahllose und absurde Aussagen, wie ein AP Mesh die Leistung erhöhen soll, ist
mir völlig unklar und macht nur Sinn, wenn man in seinem PC, macht nur Sinn, wenn man
in seinem PC in einem Eck des Hauses platziert, wo nur ein schlechtes Signal mit Paketverlusten
ankommt, ein Mesh kann das ganze sogar durch zusätzliche Hops verlangsamen, ich hab ehrlich
gesagt, das, übrigens dieser Abschnitt war der Grund, warum ich da keine wirklich ernsthafte
Antwort drauf geschrieben hab, ich konnte ihm einfach nicht folgen, wie er den Zusammenhang
zum Video herstellt, das ist, das nichts davon sag ich in dem Video, ich rede noch nicht
mal über Mesh Netzwerke in dem Video, was ich sage im Video ist, ich würde für die
400 Euro, ähm, dazu raten, damit die Wohnung ordentlich abgedeckt ist, nicht nur einen
400 Euro Router beziehungsweise Axis Point hinzustellen, sondern für 400 Euro ein paar
Axis Points im Haus zu verteilen, ich vermute darauf bezieht er sich, aber mehrere Axis
Points verteilen bedeutet ja nicht automatisch Mesh, und selbst wenn man ein WLAN Mesh macht,
ist es selbstverständlich besser als ein einzelner Router, äh, egal, keine Ahnung,
es passt einfach nicht zum Video, aber natürlich wäre auch ein Mesh selbstverständlich besser,
ja, also schreibt ja doch selbst, also erstens rede ich da nicht drüber und was, hä, ok
weiter, auch der Punkt wie der integrierte Speedtest im Router, äh, der by the way mittlerweile
völliger Standard ist bei höheren Preise, ja gut, das macht ihn ja aber nicht sinnvoller,
ich mein, nur, weil ein Hersteller Blödsinn einbaut und andere Hersteller jetzt auch Blödsinn
einbauen, wird es ja nicht weniger Blödsinn dadurch, äh, Pevion, Dankeschön für den
Platz ab, ok, also, äh, uns immer stehen geblieben, genau, also nur weil andere Hersteller Blödsinn
einbauen, wird es nicht weniger Blödsinn davon, ist völlig Banane, und jetzt kommt
komplett wirres, ich zitiere ihn mal, ahnungsloses Geschwurbel, wo ich echt keine Ahnung hab,
was er mir damit sagen will, und zwar, ein Test mit dem Handy kann nie so gut sein wie
ein Test eines gescheiten Routers, ok, schon alleine deswegen nicht, weil das Handy immer
weitere Daten aus dem Internet verarbeitet und andere Pakete des Routers gar nicht berücksichtigt,
was das Ergebnis verfälscht, das heißt, alle Leute, die Netzwerkgeräte reviewen, sollen
das gefälligst mit dem Router selbst machen und nicht mit angeschlossenen Geräten oder
was, ich weiß nicht, ob ihm klar ist, dass so ziemlich jeder seriöse Bandbreiten, Performance,
was auch immer Test, immer von einem Endgerät ausgeführt wird, immer, du kannst von einem
Endgerät einfach viel, das ist, das ist gängige Praxis, habe ich ja später auch geschrieben,
das ist vollkommen normal, du hast ja auch auf einem Endgerät, sagen wir mit iPerf oder
irgendwie was, brauchst du natürlich auch die passende Gegenstelle, auf viel mehr Konfigurationsmöglichkeiten,
wie groß sollen die Pakete sein, willst du es über TCP machen, willst du es über UDP
machen, du kannst teilweise sogar Packet-Loss simulieren und sowas, was soll denn der Test
von so einem Router aussagen, mal ganz davon abgesehen, es kommt ja sogar drauf an, dass
der Test beim Endgerät gut ist, mal überzogenes Beispiel jetzt, stellt euch vor, der Test
vom Router sagt, jawoll krasse 500 MBit, so Speedtest auf dem Endgerät sagt, ah nur
50 MBit, was habt ihr davon, dass der Router 500 MBit in seinem internen Speedtest sagt,
nix, wichtig ist, dass es am Endgerät ankommt, was ja auch eines der Gründe ist, warum man
Tests von einem Endgerät ausführt und das einfach nur sinnlose Spielerei ist, die kann
man zwar in den Router integrieren, machen es aber nicht sinnvoller, zumal Speedtest
Org ja nur wirklich jeder aufmachen kann, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass Speedtest
Org irgendwie der Scientific-Netzwerk-Test schlechthin ist, aber für ein halbwegs aussagekräftiges
Bild reicht das und es wird vom Endgerät ausgeführt, was die deutlich bessere Variante
ist, um Speedtest zu machen, weil du willst ja wissen, was kommt am Endgerät an und nicht
was sagt der Router in irgendeinem Webinterface, so also, also da leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht
ein, so, jetzt kommt das Knowhow in Person, warum, ich sage in dem Video, ich sage in
dem Video, eigentlich ist Router das falsche Wort für diese Geräte, man müsste es Multifunktionsgeräte
nennen, weil es ja nicht nur ums Routen geht und das eigentliche Routing und Routing Funktionalität
bei diesen Geräten jetzt auch gar nicht mal so sonderlich dolle ist, das sind Multifunktionsgeräte,
die zum Beispiel eine Deckbasis Station haben, einen Switch drin haben, einen Firewall drin
haben, IP Gateway Funktionalität drin haben, VPN Gateway Funktionalität drin haben, so
das sage ich im Video und dann sagt er mir, warum VPN nicht zum Routing gehört, ist mir
auch absolut rätselhaft, was ist daran rätselhaft, das sind zwei Techniken, die miteinander,
Technologien, die miteinander erst einmal gar nichts zu tun haben, man, du brauchst
in der Regel, nicht unbedingt, aber in der Regel, du brauchst funktionierendes Routing,
was du einen VPN machen kannst, aber VPN und Routing haben ja erst einmal miteinander
nichts zu tun, das sind vielleicht Sachen, die sich gegenseitig ergänzen oder du brauchst
um eine VPN Verbindung aufzuwahlen über das Internet, auf dem Weg Router, die funktionieren,
aber nichtsdestotrotz sind das zwei komplett unterschiedliche paar Techniken, das sieht
man ja auch schon daran, es gab Router lange bevor es VPN gab und im englischsprachigen
Routing Artikel auf Wikipedia taucht glaube ich nicht einmal das Wort VPN auf, also nein,
VPN gehört nicht zu Routing, das hat nichts miteinander zu tun, das sind Sachen, die man
zusammen verwenden kann, aber das eine hat mit dem anderen erst einmal technologisch
gar nichts zu tun, so und jetzt kommt was, was ich auch überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen
kann, am lautesten habe ich aber über den Punkt mit den 2,5 oder sogar 5 Gigabit Anschlüssen
gelacht, seien ernst, darauf zu antworten wäre mir jetzt echt zu doof, man dürfte nicht
vergessen er möchte eine seriöse professionelle Antwort hier drauf haben, warum keine Ahnung,
ich weiß nicht warum im Jahr 2021 der Gedanke nach 2,5 oder 5 Gigabit Anschlüssen zu Low
Brain ist, ich glaube es liegt eher daran, er weiß nicht, dass es 2,5 und 5 Gigabit Anschlüsse
gibt, also ich glaube einfach er kennt das nicht, noob doggy, ich kann da gleich, ich
sag da gleich was zu, nachdem ich mich hier um den Kollege auf YouTube der Sache angenommen
habe, also das glaube ich einfach ihm ist nicht bekannt, dass es das gibt, warum macht
er mich so schräg an, wenn er eine richtige Antwort haben will, ich habe keine Ahnung,
doch ich weiß es, ich weiß es, ich weiß warum er das macht, er macht das um, also es gibt
so Leute um sich als quasi überlegen zu präsentieren, so nach dem Motto, ich gewinne jede Diskussion
so nach, es gibt so Leute, weiß ich auch nicht, ich gehe aber davon aus, der ist auch schon
ein bisschen älter und ist irgendwie mit der Welt nicht zufrieden oder so, keine Ahnung,
kann man jetzt viel reiten interpretieren, so, aber es geht ja noch weiter, jetzt kommt
ja der Gag, der Gag des Jahrzehnts, natürlich ist es kontraproduktiv unfreundlich zu sein,
er ist, natürlich, also, aber ich finde es gut, wenn sich PC Kid ist wie Max95x, das
ist eigentlich richtig Big Brain Dis, wenn man sich das mal überlegt, wenigstens das
kann er gut, ja, Max95x FPS, übrigens, was ihm wahrscheinlich nicht klar war, wenn er
9 minus 5 rechnet, da kommt er bei 4 raus, dann stimmt es wieder, so, mit solchen Themen
befassen, jedoch würde ich hier etwas mehr Professionalität erwarten, wenn man schon
solche Videos erstellt, hat jetzt nichts damit zu tun, ob der Router überteuert, gut oder
schlecht ist, aber die Begründungen sind einfach nur für den Arsch, warum 95, ja wahrscheinlich
weil man sagen will, mit 95 ist man ein Kind, was ja schwachsinnig ist, Leute die 95 geboren
sind, sind heute auch, 25, 26, kein Schimmer, deswegen verstehe ich den Dis ja auch nicht
so richtig, aber gut, also, ich habe gedacht, okay, es hat keinen Sinn da sinnvoll drauf
zu antworten, schreibst du mal einfach irgendwas blödes, ja, normalerweise geben die Leute
dann Ruhe, wenn man eine blöde Antwort schreibt, und mir war es ehrlich gesagt, nachdem geflame,
auch zu dumm da eine richtige Antwort drauf zu schreiben, habe ich halt geschrieben, das
menschliche Auge sieht nur bis 100 MBit, okay, habe ich übrigens mir nicht ausgedacht,
kam aus dem Discord, Discord hatte die Idee für diese Big Brain Antwort, so das mag er
natürlich nicht, das mag er natürlich nicht, das findet er nicht gut, findet er nicht gut,
dann sagt er mir, genau das meine ich, mega professionell, richtiger Kindergarten oder
gehts auch mit Gegenargumenten, also man sieht, er erwartet ernsthaft auf dieses flaming
Ding, ohne wirklich Gehalt drinnen, er erwartet da wirklich, also er denkt, er hat jetzt voll
die krassen Big Brain Facts getroppt, und darauf muss man jetzt in irgendeiner Art und
Weise seriös eingehen, ja, so habe ich ihm halt drauf geahndet, na, es ist ja super,
dass dein ursprüngliches Comment auch so wahnsinnig seriös ist, professionell ist, damit habe
ich mir gedacht, damit dachte ich, es ist erledigt, dachte es ist vorbei, jetzt lässt das bleiben,
hat er aber nicht, so irgendwie hat der Discord da von Wind gekriegt und hat bisschen sich
lustig drüber gemacht, okay, so, jetzt macht er den Adrian erst nochmal blöd an, okay,
so, und jetzt ist er stinkig, jetzt ist er stinkig, weil ich nicht ordentlich drauf geantwortet
habe, jetzt muss er mir ja erst nochmal demonstrieren, wenn einer der Alpha Commentator in der Kommentarsektion
ist, dann natürlich er, das ist glaube ich eh das Ziel dieser ganzen Aktion, ich glaube
das Ziel der ganzen Aktion ist, um zu zeigen, er hat irgendwie dickes Teil in der Hose,
sowas, sowas vermute ich da mal, okay, also, mal davon abgesehen, das war keine Argumentation,
ich hatte keinen Bock auf ein sinnloses Comment zu antworten, also das hätte man eigentlich
verstehen können, so, aber es wird ja noch besser, es wird ja noch besser, es wird noch
besser, also, das ist deine ganze Argumentation, hahaha, meine Fresse, such dir ein neues Hobby,
krassert das, okay, und da war immer so irgendwelche Möchte, was soll uns eigentlich diese Smiley
dahinter jetzt sagen, ich glaube da ist einfach zu cool oder zu boomer da für Emojis zu verwenden,
gut, aber danke, you made my day, ganz ehrlich, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass ich
seinen day gemacht habe, ich glaube der war ein bisschen pissed, oder aus irgendwelchen
Gründen hat er sich nicht so geil gefühlt, wie er es gerne hätte, sonst hätte er es
jetzt gut sein lassen und nicht so nochmal wall of text mit eigentlich nicht viel Inhalt
gedroppt, so, also, okay, aber er ist ja wirklich der Meinung, er hat Ahnung und hat voll die
facts gedroppt, also richtig medge quasi, also ich erwähne mehrere Punkte, die faktisch
falsch sind, also ich habe es ja schon kurz beantwortet, es ist eigentlich so gut, also
seine Punkte sind faktisch falsch, ja das ist richtig, aber das wollte er mir da wahrscheinlich
nicht mitsagen, okay, sind aber du scheinst gar nicht erst in der Lage zu sein, damit
Gegenargumenten zu kontern, die Aussagen zu entkämpfen, muss ich wie ein kleines Kind,
okay, weil der kann es einfach nicht gut sein lassen, okay, weil das wohl auch einfach
zutrifft, ich mag es ja, wenn ich Recht habe, daran siehst du, er muss sich jetzt quasi
bestätigen dabei nochmal, aber wenn es mir so einfach gemacht wird, haha, ist halt so,
es wird immer besser, es wird immer besser, mit Möchtegern-Influencer, also ihr habt
das zuerst gehört, immer das gleiche in einem Monolog, erscheinen sie meist kompetent,
ich glaube er denkt von sich, ist so der geile, er hat mich jetzt entlarvt, er hat mich so
richtig entlarvt, er hat jetzt quasi max FPS exposed gemacht und hat quasi der Welt gezeigt,
was ich eigentlich wirklich für ein Sack bin, so, in einem Monolog erscheinen sie meist
kompetent, in jeder Diskussion sieht man dann die Realität, wir haben nochmal bei, wir
haben ja nicht mal diskutiert, er hat ein schwachsinniges Comment geschrieben, ich habe
schwachsinnig darauf geantwortet, wenn er ein ordentliches Comment geschrieben hat, dann
hätte ich auch ordentlich darauf geantwortet, so, und das geilste ist, den Fans scheint die
Korrektur der Aussagen überhaupt nicht wichtig zu sein, die Aussagen sind ja auch schwachsinnig,
die meisten Leute, die hier zugucken, haben ein bisschen IT-Ahnung und ich würde mal sagen,
die meisten, die keine Ahnung haben, können es zumindest ganz gut einschätzen, außer
er anscheinend, ich würde ihn übrigens noch nicht mal unterstellen, dass er gar keine
Ahnung hat, er ist jemand, der auf YouTube ein paar Netzwerktechnik-Videos geguckt hat
und gedacht, er hat, und jetzt denkt er, er hat voll das Experten-Status, so, einfach
nur peinlich, vor allem der Versuch, sich eloquent aus der Affäre zu ziehen, indem
man unsachlich möchte, gern witzig geht, also ich muss sagen, ich fand das eigentlich
tatsächlich ganz lustig, aber gut, kann man sich sicherlich drüber streiten, aber an
Eloquenz sind wir ihm eh allemand nicht gewachsen, das ist ja schon mal offensichtlich gewesen
im ersten Comment, also ich mein, also mit diesem Intro-Satz springt einem ja die Eloquenz
förmlich ins Gesicht, also das ist ja kaum noch zu überbieten, so, jetzt ist er fertig
mit seinem Rant, ok, das da unten, den Zusammenhang, das verstehe ich jetzt gar nicht, also was
auch immer das damit jetzt zu tun hat, naja, das erklärt auch, warum so viele Leute grün
wählen, keine Ahnung, aber nee, ich glaube echt, er denkt, er ist der krasse Exposer,
er hat mich jetzt voll, voll exposed, ich, kein Schimmer, er hat die Ausbildung zum Falschinformatiker
gemacht, das finde ich tatsächlich gut, das ist ein guter Witz, im Vergleich zu seinem
ist es sogar witzig, ok, also meine Antwort habe ich jetzt ja, gut, vielleicht noch mal
kurz das hier, ich habe mich ein bisschen, ein bisschen kontra geflammt, naja, im Prinzip
das was ich auch gesagt habe, also warum, warum, das ist schwachsinnig, ja, ich vermute
mal, es ist wirklich jemand, der hat ein paar Netzwerk-Technik-Videos geguckt auf YouTube
und hat jetzt den Eindruck, richtig krass den Durchblick zu haben, ich habe ja gehofft,
er hat geantwortet, hätten wir uns das jetzt nochmal durchlesen können, ob da irgendwie
jetzt noch was Sinnvolles, Sinnvolles kommt, aber ich gucke nochmal, er hat jetzt ja, er
hat jetzt ja irgendwie drei Stunden Zeit oder so, leider nicht, leider nicht, ok, aber eins
muss man sagen, YouTube zu machen seit 2010 hat eine Sache gebracht, also ursprünglich
haben mich so Dinge ja übelst ausgelöst immer, ich habe mich am Anfang auf YouTube
über dumme Kommentare extrem aufgeregt, weil ich mir immer gedacht habe, also nicht so
sehr über die Kommentare, sondern über die Menschen dahinter, weil ich mir immer gedacht
habe, wie dumm kann man eigentlich sein und das hat mich immer früher total aufgeregt,
aber mittlerweile sehe ich das ganz entspannt und das schockt mich eigentlich gar nicht
mehr, so jetzt muss ich erstmal Chat beantworten, ich habe doch gesagt, ich beantworte irgendwas,
wo ist es denn, irgendwas mit Altenheim war doch da, oder Pflege, hier, also, der Noob
Doc sagt, ok, also ich arbeite in einem Pflegeheim, Aloha ist wahrscheinlich Altenheim soll das
heißen oder, vermute ich mal, Autokorrektur und dort kann ich mich ins WLAN einloggen,
mit dem, mit einem Samsung Tablet klappt das auch wunderbar, nur mit dem iPhone nicht,
er sagt, mir immer unsicht, unsicheres Netz und verbindet sich nicht, was ist denn das
für ein Access, bzw. was ist denn da eingestellt, also, ist das, nach Alohaim ist das Unternehmen,
was benutzt denn das WLAN für Verschlüsselung und für Parameter, so, das weißt du nicht,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, das liegt daran, dass der Access Point, der da steht, einfach
so extrem alt ist, dass man den mal durch was Neues austauschen soll, also meine Vermutung,
ich denke mal, dass das entweder noch WEP Verschlüsselung ist, also das muss dann aber
ein Access Point sein, der 10, 15 Jahre alt ist, was ja durchaus sein kann, oder was unverschlüsselt
ist, ich kann dir leider aus dem Kopf nicht sagen, wann iOS diese Meldung bringt, aber
ich würde mal gucken, gerade wenn du das dir angucken kannst mit einem Android Tablet,
da kannst du dir mal in die Optionen gehen und dir anschauen, was da eingestellt ist,
also über was da sich verbindet, sollte das unverschlüsselt sein oder WEP, wobei ich gar
nicht weiß, meckert iOS bei einem unverschlüsselten, bei einem unverschlüsselten meckert das nicht,
aber, weil es gibt doch ganz viele offene WLANs, die man joinen kann, aber ich glaube
mit WEP meckert das, also das würde ich mal machen, ich würde mich mal verbinden mit
dem Android Tablet und gucken, was das verwendet, wenn das noch WEP ist, also WEP ist das, womit
man WLAN Security ponnt vor 15 Jahren, das ist so unsicher, dass du das innerhalb von,
wie schnell hat man WEP geknackt heute, 2 Minuten, das geht unfassbar schnell mittlerweile mit
aktueller Hardware, nee nee nee nee nee, ich habe auch WPA2 bei mir, das ist nicht unsicher,
so wie ich es verstehe, kannst du ja auch gar nicht joinen mit dem iPad oder mit dem
iPhone, ob du willst oder nicht, wo man das sieht in Android, du musst in die WLAN Einstellungen
gehen und dann bei den WLAN irgendwo auf die Settings, frag mich nicht, ich gucke mir das
viel zu selten an unter Android, es gibt bestimmt, aber das muss der Chat wissen, weil ich davon
keine Ahnung habe aus dem Kopf, es gibt bestimmt auch Apps, was z.B. ganz gut ist, Wi-Fi Scanner,
wie heißt, ich habe einen Wi-Fi Scanner auf meinem Android Tablet, um das auszuprobieren,
der ist echt nice, der da glaube ich, oder, Wi-Fi Analyzer, glaub den da, glaub den habe
ich installiert, nee, Android, weiß das gar nicht mehr, du kannst ja auch einen dieser
Apps drauf installieren auf deinem Android Tablet und da siehst du die ganzen Optionen
von den WLANs in der Umgebung, da kannst du dir hier das WLAN raussuchen und dann siehst
du hier unten die Verschlüsselung, die verwendet wird, so und wenn da irgendwas von WEP steht,
dann würde ich mir schon mal Gedanken machen, was, Analyty, nee, Analyty, Speedtest Wi-Fi
Analyzer, das kenne ich schon, habe ich nicht ausprobiert, ja das ist sicherlich auch ganz,
ganz nice, zumindest würde ich als erstes mal überprüfen, was ist denn das, sollte
das WLAN wirklich noch WEP sein, dann solltet ihr gucken, den Access Point, entweder kann
der das schon, dass man dem Access Point selbst was umstellen kann, dass der neu genug ist
und ansonsten würde ich mal schauen etwas neueren Access Point zu holen, weil WEP ist
wirklich, man kann es nicht mal mehr als unsicher bezeichnen, eigentlich offen und das will
man ja nicht.
So wie ich die kenne, hängen dann wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwelche internen Rechner im
gleichen Netz vom WLAN, die auch noch im Zweifelsfall mit Windows XP laufen, das heißt wenn es
wirklich einer drauf anlegt, da hat er zwei Minuten, dann ist er im WEP, WLAN, am Start,
scannt einmal das Netz durch, findet irgendwelche unsicher Windows XP Rechner und veranstaltet
damit irgendwelche komischen Sachen, wer hackt denn bitte Altersheime, da gibt es sicherlich
genug, so also so würde ich das jetzt machen, er hat fürs Alpha Mentoring gezahlt, ja genau
so liest sich das, was ist eigentlich aus dem Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken,
was ist aus dem Alpha Mentoring geworden, jetzt gibt es nicht mehr, warum gibt es das
nicht mehr, sorry, ich habe jetzt gespart extra, dass ich da mal dran teilnehmen kann
und jetzt gibt es das einfach nicht mehr, wer hat es davon abgesehen, also ich halte
diese ganzen, das war ja nicht ernst gemeint, also nein ich würde das nicht machen, ich
halte diese ganzen Coaching Programme generell für komplett einseitig, also der einzige
der damit Geld verdient ist der Coach beziehungsweise die Firma, die da dahinter steht oder das
sagen wir so die Paar, die vielleicht am Anfang da mit ihm Geschäfte machen, je nachdem ob
das Richtung Schneeballsystem oder Pyramide oder wie auch immer geht, letztendlich kann
es ja gar nicht funktionieren, wenn man sich überlegt, diese Programme versprechen dann
zum Beispiel, bleiben wir jetzt mal bei diesem Alpha Mentoring Geschichte, so nach dem Motto,
wenn du das machst wirst du zum Alpha, was auch immer das heißt, dann wirst du so wie
Kollege oder was auch immer, die Sache ist nur die, das kann ja von der Idee her gar
nicht funktionieren, wir schauen uns gleich das andere Video an, das kann ja von der Idee
her gar nicht funktionieren, wenn wir jetzt mal von dem fiktiven Fall ausgehen, es würden
80 Millionen in Deutschland bei irgendeinem Coach mitmachen, der einem verspricht, so
wirst du alles erreichen, was du willst, das würde ja dann bedeuten, dass auf einmal 80
Millionen Leute alles erreichen, was sie wollen, das funktioniert ja zahlenverhältnismäßig
gar nicht, wie soll das dann funktionieren?
Also es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn, ja ich weiß, Sigma Mail ist das neue, naja er
tritt dir dann als Vaterfigur entgegen und motiviert dich, mehr ist das nicht, es wird
aber als mehr verkauft, es wurde aber als mehr verkauft, diese ganzen Mentoring Programme
erzählen dir immer das Blau vom Himmel runter und wenn du schon so schlau bist, das zu durchschauen,
dann brauchst du diese Mentoring Programme auch nicht, das ist genau das gleiche, wie
die Typen, früher war es immer komm in die Gruppe oder was auch immer, das ist genau
das gleiche, die dann aus dem Auto aussteigen und erstmal den Geldscheinstapel nehmen, in
die Kamera, den krassen Lifestyle am Strand und sonst was, das ist alles so eine krasse
Show, die im Endeffekt dazu dienen soll, nicht den Leuten, denen sie quasi Reichtum verkaufen
reich zu machen, sondern einzig und allein die Coaches oder die Leute, die hinter dem
Programm stehen, das ist ja auch nichts neues Leute, das ist überhaupt nichts neues, ich
habe euch doch schon oft erzählt oder ab und zu mal zumindest erzählt, bevor es das Internet
gab, mein Vater hat die Leute auch krass gescampt früher und die Sachen waren nicht
unähnlich zu dem Scheiß, der aktuell im Internet läuft, diese Methoden sind doch uralt, mein
Vater hat damals zum Beispiel älteren Damen, man könnte auch sagen Omas erzählt, er vermittelt
ihnen quasi den Partner fürs Leben und was er in Wirklichkeit gemacht hat ist, er hat
die mega teure, übertragen wir das mal auf diese Coachingsachen, Coachingverträge verkauft,
waren nicht Coachingverträge, keine Ahnung, was da als Überschrift drauf stand und am
Endeffekt hat er es folgendermaßen gemacht, der hat 5-6 gut aussehende, nette Herren und
hat die zu den Omas heimgeschickt und die waren alle super verliebt und haben sich auf
den Scam eingelassen und haben ein Jahresabo abgeschlossen, also die Scam-Methoden sind
uralt schon pre-Internet, also ja natürlich ist das gemein und wisst ihr aber was das
lustige daran ist, das ist legal, danke schön Tischende für den Sub, das ist legal, die
haben ihn ja versucht zu verklagen und der Richter muss wohl, ich war da nicht dabei,
ich war da noch klein, das ist schon eine Weile her, der Richter hat dann als so eine
von den älteren Damen da war und die sich so einen Vertrag angeguckt haben, der muss
die wohl wirklich gefragt haben, warum um alles in der Welt haben sie das unterschrieben,
wie können sie sowas unterschreiben, also da siehst du schon mal was da wohl drinnen
stand, also sie hat die Hardcore gescampt und was ich damit sagen will ist, diese Methoden
sind uralt, die sind nichts Neues, warum sollte das im Internet irgendwie anders sein?
Tja und übrigens, falls ihr euch fragt, was da draus geworden ist, der ist pleite gegangen
damit und hat mehr oder weniger die ganze Kohle verloren, die er damit gemacht hat,
also ich habe nichts geerbt, ich werde nichts erben und wenn ich was erbe, dann eher einiges
an Schulden, ne ne der lebt noch, der lebt noch, also es hat sich noch nicht mal gelohnt
die Leute zu scammen, das muss man sagen, da sind die Internet Scammer besser, bei denen
lohnt sich das glaube ich zumindest zum größten Teil, so also, wir gucken uns jetzt das Video
an, also auf geht's, Zwangsfilter für alle, gucken wir mal an, gegen Pornogewalt und Co,
und Co ist immer, ist immer verdächtig, das wirkt immer wie so ein Wildcard für alles,
wie hat er die Kohle, der ist pleite gegangen mit dem Laden, das ging ja wohl, ging anscheinend
nicht, also er ist pleite gegangen, weil er hat es dann halt ein bisschen zu sehr übertrieben
mit seinem Scamme, da muss der Konkurs anmelden, hatte ordentlich Schulden und die Kohle war
wieder alle weg, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht gar so sehr im Detail erzählen, ich weiß,
es haben damals auch Zeitungen drüber berichtet, also lokale Sachen in Frankfurt, da war richtig
Kacke am Darm, so gucken wir das jetzt mal, auf geht's, was, hab ich noch nie gehört,
welcher Statistik man folgt und auch bei den Gewaltvideos sieht es ähnlich aus, dass die
ganz weit oben stehen bei den Suchanfragen, OnlyFans, auch eine Plattform, wo es um nackte
Menschen geht, ist ebenfalls dabei, auch auf YouTube gibt es mittlerweile viele Gewaltdarstellungen,
auch wenn Google sich bemüht, da so viel wie möglich von fern zu halten, Fakt ist jedenfalls,
dass auch Jugendliche unter 18 Jahren wissen, wie man an die entsprechenden Videos rankommt,
Jugendschutz im Internet, das ist immer noch ein rotes Tuch für deutsche Jugendschützer,
ich hab euch letztens gesagt, dass man versucht hat mit irgendwelchen Schreiben, Pornhub und
Co. dazu zu bewegen, dass sie mehr Jugendschutz einführen, aber das hat nicht geklappt und
deswegen versucht man jetzt was ganz anderes, man möchte Zwangsfilter für fast alle großen
Web-Seiten einführen und nur OnlyFans wissen, wie man OnlyFans ist.
Also nur Tier-3-Subs, also bescheuerte, wie soll das funktionieren, ich hab manchmal
das Gefühl, die Leute, die sich das ausdenken, haben absolut keinen Bezug zur Realität, kein
Bezug zu technischen Möglichkeiten und hören auch nicht auf Leute, die Ahnung davon haben.
Krass wie der Upload-Filter, vielleicht nicht sogar noch krasser, wenn es so käme, wie
es gerade geplant ist, zeige ich euch in diesem Video.
Hallo, ich bin Christian Solmecke, Rechtsanwalt und Partner der Kölner Medienrechtskanzlei
Wilde Beuger und Solmecke und lasst gerne ein Abo für diesen Kanal da, wenn euch rechtliche
Themen interessieren.
Ich habe euch vor einiger Zeit schon mal berichtet von den Brandbriefen, die die Landesmedien
anstalten, die dafür zuständig sind in Deutschland an Pornhub und Co. gesendet haben, da hieß
es entweder ihr führt eine wirksame Altersverifikation ein oder wir werden euch abschalten und zwar
auf Netzebene, das heißt wir werden euch nicht mehr durchleiten bei der Deutschen Telekom,
bei Vodafone und Co.
Ich finde es übrigens auch ein absolutes Unding, dass man die Provider quasi verpflichtet,
also nicht nur die Provider, auf der einen Seite die Provider und auf der anderen Seite
die Content-Anbieter oder Content-Hoster, also sowas wie YouTube, immer mehr verpflichtet,
da, wie nennt man das, quasi polizeiliche, ich weiß nicht, ob das der korrekte Begriff
ist, aber ich glaube, ihr wisst, was ich meine, quasi polizeiliche Aufgaben auszuüben,
das finde ich ein absolutes Unding.
Der erste Schritt, den man versucht hat, ehrlicherweise auf diese Briefe hat es nicht viel passiert
und kleinlich haben die, oder ganz klein laut haben dann die Landesmedienanstalten gesagt,
naja, es ist nicht so einfach die Rechtsdurchsetzung in fernen Ländern, denn da sitzen diese Pornoplattformen
in aller Regel und schaut man sich dann eben diese Plattform an, steht da ein dicker Banner,
ich bin 18, ja, nein, und wenn ihr ja anklickt, kommt ihr eben rein, das ist sicherlich nicht
die Altersverifikation, die sich die, jetzt weiß ich endlich, wie das funktioniert, Medienschützer
wünschen.
Deswegen kommen Sie jetzt mit einer neuen alten Idee um die Ecke und ehrlicherweise ist
das ein Ausdruck purer Verzweiflung, was ich an dieser Stelle sagen, Sie haben einen Gesetzesentwurf
vorgestellt.
Eins, ich guck gleich weiter, also eins kann ich euch garantieren, wir haben in den letzten
paar Jahren viel Schwachsinn gesehen, es haben alle Seiten die letzten Jahre über, ja zumindest
mein Eindruck, mehr demonstriert als es noch die Jahre davor der Fall war, aber wenn Sie
eins schaffen wollen, also wenn Sie wirklich eins machen müssen um die Bevölkerung komplett
gegen sich aufzubringen, dann ist es Pornos sperren, ich sag's euch, wenn Umweltschutz
oder Klimawandel, Corona und sonst was noch nicht gereicht haben, um welche Seite auch
immer auf die Straßen zu bringen, wenn die Pornos sperren, Tempolimit, egal was, wenn
die Pornos sperren, dann ist vorbei, dann ist dritter Weltkrieg.
Corona sagt, wir müssen schon auf Betriebssystemebenen, und zwar auf jeglichen Betriebssystemen,
was irgendwie Zugang ins Internet ermöglicht, blocken und filtern und dieser Gesetzesentwurf
der stammt eigentlich aus April 2020, wo dabei im März diesen Jahres noch mal in größerer
Runde im Rahmen der Gesamtkonferenz der Landesmedienanstalten diskutiert und er liegt
jetzt vor, der hat's also wirklich wirklich in sich, ich werf mal ganz kurzen Blick drauf,
die Jungs von spielrecht.de, die haben den online gestellt.
Ach ja, seit heute darf man ja auch den Rundfunkbeitrag, wenn ich's richtig verstanden hab, wieder
erhöhen, wie man lustig ist, ne, auch so ein Ding, ja.
Rot um die neuesten Änderungen, da sieht man hier schon Paragraph 2, Geltungsbereich,
dieser Staatsvertrag, also Jugendmedien-Staatsvertrag, da geht's drum, dieser Staatsvertrag gilt
für Rundfunk und Telemedien im Sinne des Medien-Staatsvertrags und da hat man einfach
noch einen halben Satz daran gesagt, so wie für Betriebssystemen im Sinne des Paragraphen
3, also plötzlich sagt man, ja, jetzt regeln wir auch die Betriebssysteme, also alles,
was irgendwie…
Wie soll das denn funktionieren, soll Microsoft, also Linux kannst du knicken.
Manchmal bin ich echt froh, ihr wisst, ich flame immer mal ganz gerne, dass ich das gerade
auf dem Desktop Linux technisch, finde ich, nicht in die richtige Ecke entwickelt, aber
gerade wenn man sowas sieht, können wir froh sein, dass wir sowas wie Linux haben.
Sollte diese ganzen Gehirnfirze, die da so rumspucken, wirklich mit der Zeit durchkommen,
dann bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig, als Linux zu verwenden.
… irgendwie ein technisches Gerät betreibt und das können viele sein, das kann im Prinzip
auch euer smarter Kühlschrank sein und smarten Autos und und und die sollen jetzt hier plötzlich
blocken.
Und was ein Betriebssystem ist, wird eben auch bestimmt, die Menge der als Schnittstelle
zwischen Software und Hardware erforderlichen Programme für den Betrieb eines Geräts über
das Zugang zu Angeboten nach Nummer eins ermöglicht wird, also über das man quasi
ins Internet kommt, denn das ist das Angebot der Inhalt von Telemedien, ist alles ein bisschen
verschachtelt diese Gesetze, aber im Wesentlichen, ich bin ja euer Translator für Gesetze, heißt
das, alle Software, die ihr euch ins Internet bringt, auf Betriebssystemebene wird künftig
reguliert werden und diese Regulierung, die haben wir dann weiter unten, was alles auf
Betriebssystemebene…
Mir geht dieser unglaubliche Regulierungstzwang, ich sage ja nicht, dass Regeln unsinnig sind,
aber ohne Regeln könnten wir hier nicht ordentlich leben, es muss schon gewisse Regeln geben,
wo sich alle darauf verständigen und auch alle dran halten und die, die sich nicht dran
halten, die können halt nicht mehr daran teilnehmen, es ist schon wichtig, dass es
Regeln gibt.
Aber mir geht es unglaublich auf den Sack, das hat die letzten drei, vier Jahre extrem
zugenommen, dass man jeden Scheiß erstmal, anstatt sich zu überlegen, gibt es nicht
irgendwie sinnvolle Lösungsansätze, dass man erstmal schreit, wir müssen das verbieten.
Nach dem Motto, ok, Autos in die Innenstädte, verbieten, ja aber ok, die Leute kommen nicht
mehr auf die Arbeit, öffentlicher Nahverkehr ist kacke, ist egal, müssen wir verbieten,
Feuerwerk verbieten.
Leute, ich mache ewig kein Feuerwerk mehr, ich finde es auch nicht sinnvoll, ehrlich
gesagt, Feuerwerk zu machen, aber es muss doch für die meisten Belange irgendwie eine
gangbare Regelung geben, die nicht alles oder nichts ist.
Wir verbieten alles, auf was wir keinen Bock haben, ist doch beschissen.
Blockt werden soll, es geht um entwicklungsbeeinträchtigende Angebote, klaro, solche Pornoangebote sind
das und bei der Beurteilung geht es um verschiedene Mechanismen und auch um exzessive Mediennutzung,
das muss also wer etwas süchtig macht, das kommt also mit rein und da muss man Altersverifikationsstufen
haben, was wie geeignet ist, wie soll das funktionieren, Null reingekommen, ab Null,
ab Null, da kommt da Penobeer um die Ecke, diese Webseite braucht so eine Altersverifikation.
Naja, und dann geht das Gesetz weiter, es ist also relativ viel, was da noch kommt,
hat man eben ein Mechanismus und die Voreinstellung ist erstmal alle Webseiten zu blockieren,
die nicht für unter 18-jährige geeignet sind, das heißt also, wenn die Webseiten keine
entsprechende Response geben und nicht wissen, das Betriebssystem nicht weiß, ab welchem
Alter ist diese Webseite, soll im Mechanismus dieses Gesetzes erstmal alles geblockt werden,
das ist eben diese Verzweiflung, die ich gerade sagte, was filtert, was das Zeug hält,
und im Zweifel locken wir erstmal alles, was uns nicht sagt, ob es über oder unter 18
Jahre.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt bedeutet das, also wenn man das jetzt mal ganz strikt auslegt,
wenn ich das jetzt so verstanden habe, was er sagt, das Internet ist dann keine, ja keine,
es ist dann eine Whitelist im Endeffekt, also quasi, es ist alles geblockt und nicht zugänglich,
was nicht vorher als ist okay gelistet wird.
Das heißt ja, es ist fast wie bei den China-Chinesen, also man soll die Kirche im Dorf lassen.
Also Grundeinstellung ist, dieser Betriebssystem ist erstmal unter 18 und ja, man muss eben
dann als Nutzer ein höheres Alter nachweisen, wenn man auch demnächst gucken sich die Chinesen
von uns Sachen ab, wie könnte man das machen, das ist natürlich insgesamt ein wahnsinniger
technischer Aufwand, man muss alle Betriebssysteme umprogrammieren und vor allen Dingen jede
Webseite muss sich darauf einstellen, dass sie eben den Betriebssystem für welches
Alter sie geeignet ist, das ist erstmal nur einstufen der Webseite selbst und wenn die
wieder falsch liegt oder sich falsche einstuft, kann es Bußgelder geben, deswegen sollten
Webseiten tunlichst das richtige Alter angeben, das ist ganz klar hier.
Fakt ist jedenfalls, die wenigsten Webseitenbetreiber haben nur Seiten für Deutschland, die meisten
kommen eh aus dem internationalen Bereich und ob die jetzt für Deutschland das alles
umprogrammieren, wird sich zeigen, wohl eher nicht.
Fakt ist ebenfalls auch, dass dann ein Großteil des Internets erstmal gesperrt wird.
Genau, sag ich doch, dass das was ich gesagt habe, das ist quasi das Internet wird zur
Blacklist.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, kontroverses Wort darf man eigentlich gar nicht mehr sagen, ist ja
auch so ein Ding, aber ich glaube die meisten wissen, was mit Blacklist gemeint ist, nämlich
du hast halt erstmal alles geblockt und nur explizit Dinge, die erlaubt sind, kommen durch.
Gegenteil von der Blacklist, du kannst ins Internet, manche Sachen sind geblockt.
Das ist eben das System und ihr müsstet eben aufwendig dafür sorgen, dass ihr sagt, ey
ich kann auch alles nehmen, über 18 und es müsste dann wieder freigeschätzt werden.
Also erstmal blocken, das ist sozusagen der Entwurf und das eben, ja weißt du, im Smartphone
kann ich ja auch mit browsen und dann muss also Apple zusehen, dass sie in ihrer, was
ist das?
Welches Betriebssystem wird am wenigst verwendet, kann aber einen aktuellen Browser ausfüllen
von irgendeinem BSD, neben irgendeinem BSD.
Es ist 15 oder was wir da gerade haben oder 14 System entsprechend reinprogrammiert bekommen,
dass da nichts mehr weiter angezeigt wird, ein Zwangsfilter für jeden.
Das ist komplett hirnrissig.
Bei jedem Gerät und wir müssen auch jedes einzelne Gerät mühsam wieder verifizieren
und ehrlicherweise bin ich mal gespannt, wie die das machen wollen, wenn mehrere Leute
den Computer nutzen, also wir haben einen Laptop, den nutzt meine Frau, den nutze ich,
gut dann muss das Account gebunden sein.
Das ist ja auch dann tatsächlich blöde, wenn man das auf Betriebssystem eben gesagt hat.
Doch doch, man kann, klar kannst du Tor verwenden, aber Tor ist lahm, du willst doch nicht ernsthaft,
bleiben wir jetzt mal bei dem Beispiel, irgendwelche Pornhub Videos über Tor Browser streamen,
also vielleicht wenn das mal einer macht, macht das vielleicht halbwegs flüssig in
360p laufen, aber nicht wenn das mehrere machen.
Das Laptop.
Die Idee wird im Endeffekt nicht anders übrig bleiben, ich sag's euch, irgendwann wird es
so sein, dass Länder, die nicht für, sag mal mal, wie soll ich sagen, Freiheit und
Offenheit bekannt sind, unser Gateway ins Internet werden, weil die bei uns total durchdrehen.
Es gibt jetzt schon viele VPN-Anbieter, glaubt ihr, wo, im Iran war das, hab ich letztens
gelesen, glaub ich, weil der Iran ist jetzt nicht gerade dafür bekannt, dass da Friede
Freude ist, ja, und da geht dann viel über VPN ins Internet, ich glaub der Iran war das,
hab ich letztens gelesen, VPN, Endpunkte gibt's da wohl einige, und kann doch nicht sein,
dass es auf so was rausläuft, oder?
Laptops ist immer 18, dann haben die die wahrscheinlich so im Kopf, dass man verschiedene Lock-ins
hat beim Betriebssystem und dann da pro Lock-in das nochmal unterschiedlich macht, also das
ist nun wirklich die...
Chat, reißt euch zusammen.
... Idee, die man haben kann, wenn man nicht mehr weiß, wie man an die ganzen Porno- und
Gewalt-Anbieter im Netz rankommt, auf Betriebssystem-Ebene zu blocken.
Was ich gar nicht so ganz verstehe, die hatten ja eigentlich geplant, dass sie die Netzsperren
intensivieren wollen, da gab's aber auch einige Gerichtsurteile dagegen, dass das
teilweise zu hart blocken würde, oder Netzsperren können natürlich auch easy umgangen werden,
das wisst ihr alle, ich brauch einfach nur, es wird ja meist auf Domain-Ebene geblockt.
Jetzt muss er sich überlegen, wie drück ich das jetzt am besten aus, dass ich hier keine
Anleitung ins Video einbaue.
Also, da gab's schon einige Tricks, die mir auch hier unter diesen YouTube-Videos präsentiert
worden sind, wie ihr sowas blockt.
Schauen wir mal weiter rein, oder umgeht, ins Netz, ins Gesetz.
So, da geht's also, die Landesmedienanstalten sollen das regeln, das ist jetzt der neue
Entwurf, und dann eben Diensteanbieter nach § 4.5 treffen, die fremde Information für
Nutzer speichern oder bereitstellen, journalistische redaktionärgestaltete Angebote nicht selbst
verantworten, treffen wirksame Wahrung der Schutzziele.
Ja, das heißt, jede Webseite muss bei dem Scheiß mitmachen.
Ja, da geht's, Meldebutton müssen die anbieten, Melde-Abhilfe-Verfahren mit einer für Kinder
und Jugendlichen geeigneten Benutzerführung, kann man auch so sagen, diese Webseite richtet
sich nicht an Minderjährige, dann brauchen die Beratungsangebote, Hilfemöglichkeiten
für, sagen wir mal, Sucht.
Wisst ihr, was ich ja auch immer ein bisschen bedenklich dran finde, jetzt mal neben dem,
was ich schon gesagt habe, wir überschlagen uns mittlerweile so mit verbotenen Regularien
und gerade was technische Sachen angeht, irgendwie an den Haaren herbeigezogenen Dinger,
man muss ja auch mal sehen, es hat seinen Grund, dass wir in Deutschland, aber auch
sagen wir mal so in Europa, Irland war da mal eine Zeit lang ein bisschen die Ausnahme,
dass wir kaum wirklich so Start-up technologiemäßig irgendwie da gegen, sagen wir mal, die USA
einstinken können.
Das ist ja kein Wunder, du musst ja erst mal durch drei Mal die Welt umrunden, fünf
Mal durch den Reifen springen, bis du irgendwas machen darfst.
Geschichten, ja, solche Dinge.
Einfach eine Streaming-Seite mal hier in Deutschland ans Netz bringen, kannst vergessen.
Wobei es eigentlich gar nicht schlecht wäre, hätte man vielleicht mal YouTube-Konkurrenz.
Aber wer, jetzt mal ernsthaft, wer ist masochistisch genug in Deutschland eine Video-Streaming-Plattform
starten zu, also in Richtung YouTube, ich rede jetzt nicht irgendwie von komische, was
weiß ich, Mediathek von ARD oder sowas, wer möchte, wer würde wirklich ernsthaft versuchen
in Deutschland sowas zu starten?
Nein, eine Einrichtung von Voreinstellungen, die Nutzungsrisiken für Kinder und Jugendliche
unter Berücksichtigung ihres Alters standardisiert begrenzen, in dem insbesondere ohne ausdrücklich
anlässlich lautige Einbildung Nutzerprofile aufgefunden werden können, noch für nicht
angemeldete Personen einsehbar sind, Standorte und Kontaktdaten und die Kommunikation mit
anderen Nutzerinnen nicht veröffentlicht werden und so weiter.
Was?
Dass also da die Kinder nicht zu viel von sich preisgeben.
Das müssen Webseiten-Programme.
Aber das eine hat doch mit dem anderen erstmal gar nichts zu tun.
Natürlich sollte man Webseiten nicht fördern, die explizit quasi Kinder mit für Kinder
ungeeigneten Inhalten auf die Seite locken wollen, das ist ja klar, aber wie wollen
sie das denn?
Wenn man ein Angebot im Inland mehr als 500.000 Nutzer hat, frage ich mich ehrlicherweise,
wenn ich sowas lese, also noch ein paar andere Sachen.
NTB, das ist das, was ich vorhin auch gemeint habe.
Journalistisch redaktionell gestaltete Angebote, nicht selbst verantworten und über 500.000
Nutzer haben, im Monat, im Jahr, man weiß es nicht.
Dann wäre es ja sinnvoller, wisst ihr was sinnvoller wäre?
Bin ich auch kein Fan von, weil ich immer noch der Meinung bin, hauptsächlich müssen,
wenn du Kinder, du kannst nicht in den Rechner einschalten, Kinder vorsetzen, da hat sich
noch nie damit beschäftigt.
Dann wäre es ja fast sinnvoller, und wie gesagt, bin ich auch nicht dafür, du machst verpflichtend,
dass die Eltern mit ihren Kindern einen zweiwöchentlichen Internetkurs besuchen müssen, wo erzählt wird,
okay, was sind die Gefahren, wie kann man sich davor schützen, bla bla bla.
Das wäre vielleicht für die Eltern auch nicht verkehrt.
Ich bin auch kein Fan davon, sowas immer als Pflicht aufzuerlegen, aber das wäre ja
immer noch sinnvoller, als diese Regulatoriens-Wildwüchse da, man könnte sich auch überlegen, macht
man in der Schule mehr Bildung in der Richtung, gibt ja durchaus Varianten, um Kinder besser
auf die Gefahren im Internet hinzuweisen, wobei man halt ehrlich sagen muss, es würde mich
wundern, wenn es heute anders wäre, dass die Kinder nicht besser Bescheid wissen im Internet
als die Eltern.
Ich meine, ich bin die Eltern-Generation mit 37 und für mich ist sowas wie Snapchat ein
Buch mit sieben Siegeln, ja, und ich bin schon Internet- und Technikaffin, aber von Snapchat
habe ich keine Ahnung, ich glaube, Snapchat ist mittlerweile auch schon wieder outdated,
das verwendet ja glaube ich auch schon keiner mehr, und natürlich, du musst als Erziehungsberechtigter
ein Auge auf deine Kinder haben, ganz klar, anders wird das nicht funktionieren, und man
muss ja auch mal sagen, ich meine, ich bin die erste Generation, ich sage nicht, dass
man das den Eltern alles alleine aufhalsen sollte, aber die hauptsächliche Verantwortung
liegt nun mal da, und ich bin ja die erste Generation, die so richtig mit Internet komplett,
nicht von klein auf, aber von ziemlich jung auf, aufgewachsen ist.
Ja, ich bin 1984 geboren, ab 98 hat sie langsam aber sicher dann mal, oder ab 6, 9 hat sie
eine Mode im ISDN, oder 95, dann hat sie irgendwann später 9, 9 rum, 8, 9, 9, 2000 DSL, ich bin
dann damit aufgewachsen, und meine Eltern hatten davon keinen Plan, ich habe auch keinen
psychischen Schaden davongetragen, und ich habe mir wirklich den größten Rotz im Internet
angeguckt, den es zur damaligen Zeit gab, klar, heute gibt es bestimmt noch mehr, aber ich
habe fast alles irgendwie schon mal gesehen, glaube ich, also es gibt fast nichts, was ich
mir damals nicht, ich habe mir wirklich den allergrößten Rotz angeguckt, die ekligsten
Beschiss, also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, Sachen, die es gibt, einfach nur, weil man
immer abgedrehtere Sachen gucken will, ja, und irgendwann bin ich dann zu dem Punkt gekommen,
als ich gesagt habe, ok, Max, du weißt, wie viel gestörte Sachen es im Internet gibt,
du musst nicht mehr jedes Video, was dir irgendwie einer verlinkt, angucken, und heute
mache ich das auch so, wenn ich irgendwelche Videolinks bekomme, oder wenn ich irgendwelche
Suchmaschinergebnisse sehe, oder sowas, wo sich er ahnen lässt, was es ist, und ich
weiß, dass das was ist, was mich so seelisch belasten könnte, dann mache ich das einfach
nicht mehr auf, ich habe heute nicht mehr den Drang, alles an Links anzuklicken, was
es so gibt, und ich glaube, das ist etwas, wo jeder früher oder später hinkommen muss,
oder wird uns, da wird uns kein Gesetz irgendwie vorschützen, ja.
Ich an der Stelle noch etwas, unausgegoren der Gesetzesentwurf, also in der letzten Sekunde
hat man so etwas reingekommen, zum Glück muss man sagen, also es gibt noch andere Dinge,
die hier geregelt sind, zum Glück muss man sagen, ist der Sturm gegen dieses neue Gesetz
ziemlich groß.
Ja, bringt ja, bringt ja nichts, haben wir ja gelernt, haben wir ja gelernt, bei Uploadfiltern,
bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung, sonst was, über die nächsten Jahre in Salamitaktik, in Scheibchenform,
in immer wieder unbenannten Dingern kommt das früher oder später alles.
Also ausgesprochen dagegen haben sich die Verbände Bitkom, Eco, Game, Vnet, Bitkom,
das sind die, die immer was von Fachkräftemangel in der IT erzählen, ZVEI und die Spitzenorganisation
der Filmwirtschaft, die SPIO, außerdem sind dagegen die Selbstregulierungsinstanzen FSK,
FSF, SSM und USK, die haben alle einen Brief an die Staatskanzleien geschrieben und gesagt,
Moment, so die Medienleute sind dagegen und die Regulatorin, wie auch immer, die sind
auch dagegen, gibt es irgendjemanden, der dafür ist, außer die, die dieses Gesetz
erstellen, aber irgendjemand muss ja dafür sein.
Überhaupt nicht, dass ihr solche tiefgreifenden Filter auf Betriebssystemeben etablieren
wollt und damit das Internet in seiner jetzigen Form wirklich massiv verändern werdet.
Also meinetwegen Netflix und Co. brauchen natürlich dann auch entsprechende Meldeputten,
ob die die einführen werden, wird sich zeigen, Twitter braucht solche Aufklärungssysteme,
alle diejenigen, die keine eigenen redaktionellen Inhalte haben, müssen diese ganzen Filter
einführen und wenn das passiert, ist das erst mal ab 18 und wird erst mal geblendet.
Ich sag doch, das Internet wird zur Whitelist, das ist das, was effektiv passiert, das ist
alles gesperrt, also ohne Scheiß, wenn das durchkommt, dann steht irgendeine chinesische
Delegation bei uns vor der Tür und fragt uns, sagt mal, könnt ihr uns erzählen, wie
habt ihr das gemacht?
Die Chinesen wären neidisch drauf.
Die Chinesen sind der Mechanismus, der hier stattfinden soll.
Die Nutzer, ehrlicherweise, auch nicht ganz so cool, weil die Nutzer selbst dann ja ständig
alles mögliche an Betriebssystemen freigeben und einstellen müssen.
Aber es ist so das letzte bisschen, was man hier versucht, um das Internet in den Griff
zu bekommen, habe ich das Gefühl Schutz von Kindern ist doch im Griff.
Es wird seit 20 Jahren erzählt, das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, das Internet
war noch nie ein rechtsfreier Raum, steht in irgendeinem Gesetz drinnen, das ist verboten,
aber im Internet erlaubt oder was?
...jugendlich in allen Ehren, aber ob Zwangsfilter das erreichen können oder ob nicht nachher
jedes Kind einfach sagt, ich bin 18 auf Betriebssystemebene und damit das Ganze noch leichter umgangen
werden kann als alle anderen bisherigen, naja, jetzt auch nicht ganz so erfolgreichen Versuche,
weiß ich ehrlicherweise auch nicht, mich würde aber interessieren, was haltet ihr von diesen
Zwangsfiltern?
Gut, das, was ich gerade gesagt habe, ist rechtlich sicherlich nicht ganz richtig,
aber diese Aussage kommt seit 20 Jahren früher bei Killerspielen und jetzt immer letzten
Jahre immer wieder bei allen möglichen Themen.
Das Internet darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein, das hört sich immer so an, wie im Internet,
quasi auf der nächsten Seite nach Google, werden öffentlich Kinder gefressen, so nach
dem Motto hört sich das immer an.
So nach dem hoh das Internet, was da alles abgeht, ai ai ai ai ai ai ai ai, also...
Dass man jetzt auf Betriebssystem...
Das Internet ist doch im Griff, das Internet ist eher immer weniger im Griff durch den
ganzen Scheiß die letzten Jahre über.
Wirklich sehr, sehr neu und das scheint wirklich aus der Mottenkiste nochmal ausgegraben worden
zu sein, plötzlich Filter setzen will, die sind erstmal ganz ganz strikt und da heißt
es, ähm, kein Content über 18 und wenn nichts eingestellt worden ist, ist er eben auch über
18. Und dann habt ihr nur noch ein paar Seiten, die ihr aufrufen könnt.
Ich finde es idiotisch, muss ich fairerweise sagen.
Ich finde es völlig an der Realität vorbei.
Mäßig wie wir es schon beim Uploadfilter erlebt haben.
Ich kann es also ich habe aber ich habe es mal Uploadfilter auch schon.
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen.
Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, dass das kommt, dass sie das wirklich durchsetzen.
Aber der Entwurf ist jetzt erst mal da.
Und sagen wir mal, da zum Glück ist jetzt ein starker Wind
von von mächtigen IT-Verbänden.
Das ist ein bisschen anders als beim Uploadfilter.
Da gab es nur uns als Community, die die gegen machen mussten.
Who care uns? Ja, das verstehe ich auch.
Hier haben wir wirklich mächtige Verbände.
Wie haben sie die Leute genannt?
Haben sie nicht gesagt, irgendwelche Bots haben demonstriert?
Kann ich dir... Bots, genau was sagst du?
Irgendwelche Bots, die auf die Barrikaden gehen, die ich euch vorhin mal genannt habe.
Insofern habe ich da die Hoffnung, dass die auf Verbands Ebene
noch ein bisschen Einfluss ausüben werden bei den Staatskanzleien.
Aber erst mal alles blocken, sperren.
Geht mir eh auf den Senkel, muss ich sagen.
Das hat mir beim Uploadfilter schon auf den Senkel.
Und jetzt hier aber fast noch mehr, dass die Betriebssysteme
da entsprechend die Filter schon implementiert haben sollen.
Ich bin gespannt, was da kommt und werde natürlich euch auch weiter
auf dem Laufenden halten.
Das ist leider schon relativ weit fortgeschritten.
Ich finde es cool, dass das jetzt richtig jetzt mit Green Screen und allem.
Ich finde, das sieht irgendwie auch von der Beleuchtung her besser
und freundlicher und schöner gestaltet aus als die Beton Wand, die sie früher hatten.
Früher hatte Beton Wand nicht ein Buch auf dem Tisch.
Fertig.
Ihr seht schon, ich bin kein Großer.
Also so finde ich das deutlich ansprechend.
Und wenn ihr das auch nicht seid, lasst gerne einen Daumen nach oben da.
Ist das überhaupt ein Green Screen?
Das ist eine Wand mit einer mit einer RGB Leuchte, oder?
Moment, ich dachte, das ist das Green Screen.
Moment, es ist eine Lampe mit einer RGB Leuchte.
Ach so.
Ha, siehst du, okay, habe ich jetzt gar nicht.
Egal, egal, Effekt ist ja der gleiche.
Und schreibt unten was in die Kommentare.
Ansonsten habe ich hier noch.
Es sieht viel besser aus als vorher.
Beleuchtung von vorne auch Hintergrund viel besser als früher.
Das neuen Jugendmedienschutz Staatsvertrag ist die Farbe.
Nee, ich finde, die Farbe passt zu der Beleuchtung.
Finde ich echt.
Ich finde, sieht ansprechend aus.
Vielleicht ist auch mein innerer innerer Kappa Pride, der da durchkommt.
Keine Ahnung mit den Jungen, mit dem Staatsvertrag.
Ich finde, das sieht gut aus.
Ich halte euch auf jeden Fall auf dem Laufenden.
Wir sehen uns morgen an gleicher Stelle schon wieder.
Tschüss und bis dahin.
CU. So, mal ganz schnell gucken, ob mein Lieblingskommentator noch geantwortet hat.
Hallo Leute.
Aber das will ich jetzt will ich mir jetzt noch mal angucken.
Wo ist er?
Nee, gut, der hat natürlich an einem Freitag besseren Abend, so als richtiger Alphamann
was besseres zu tun, als auf YouTube zu kommentieren.
Das ist ja logisch.
So, also Leute, schon was zu Steam Deck gesagt.
Ja, habe ich ein eigenes Video zugemacht.
Ich mache jetzt das hier.
Nee, ich habe es jetzt schon zugemacht.
Guck mal, der Chat verlinkt dir das bestimmt gerne.
Ich mache jetzt Bettge.
Wir sehen uns, bis denn.
CU.